bundespräsident steinmeier befürworter
und gegner der impfpflicht eingeladen
hat und mit ihnen gleich diskutieren
wird zu dieser diskussion am heutigen
morgen braucht deutschland
eine allgemeine impfpflicht im kampf
gegen die korona pandemie was spricht
dafür was spricht dagegen darüber wollen
wir heute vormittag miteinander
diskutieren und
wenn nötig auch respektvoll miteinander
streiten eines vorweg als
bundespräsident werde ich mich in dieser
runde nicht zum jahr dann eine
allgemeine impfpflicht positionieren das
gebietet schon der respekt vor dem
politischen prozess der in den kommenden
wochen zur parlamentarischen
entscheidung über ein gesetz führen kann
und soll
ein gesetz das anschließend dann dem
bundespräsidenten zur prüfung vorliegen
wird und der über seine ausfertigung zu
entscheiden hat warum also lade ich sie
heute zu dieser diskussion ein der
bundespräsident schreibt keine gesetze
aber er hat die aufgabe und ich
persönlich
glaube er hat auch die pflicht die
öffentliche auseinandersetzung
mit schwierigen und schwerwiegenden
fragen einzufordern
das ist die betonung
um die es mir heute geht mir geht es um
die debatte in der impfpflicht debatte
meine damen und herren es gibt keine
demokratie ohne debatte und es gibt auch
in krisenzeiten keine demokratie ohne
debatte der ausnahmezustand der pandemie
der höh zwar den druck auf staatliches
handeln aber
ersetzt nicht die notwendigkeit
argumente zu wägen interessen
auszugleichen im gegenteil gerade weil
wir über ein solch einschneidende
maßnahmen sprechen müssen wir an ihre
begründung besonders hohe ansprüche
stellen und erst recht deshalb weil eine
impfpflicht über lange zeit in bund und
ländern
explizit ausgeschlossen wurde umso
deutlicher
müssen doch jetzt die argumente für die
notwendigkeit eine impfpflicht im
öffentlichen raum
diskutiert würden parlamente parteien
regierungen sie alle sind dazu
aufgefordert ihre argumente in den raum
zu stellen
und gemeinsam mit bürgerinnen und
bürgern zu diskutieren
mit denen die von einer solchen
weitreichenden maßnahmen tatsächlich
betroffen sein werden eine allgemeine
impfpflicht ist für bundestag und
bundesregierung ebenfalls gewiss kein
gesetzgeberischer alltag genauso darf
auch der prozess der debatte der
abwägung der begründung nicht alltäglich
sein eine solch außerordentliche
maßnahme stellt unseren staat auch in
eine außerordentliche pflicht vor seinen
bürgerinnen und bürgern kurz gesagt
impfpflicht
bedeutet debatten pflicht genau deshalb
sind wir heute hier wir suchen die
debatte und zunächst was sagen uns die
wissenschaftlichen fakten die neuesten
sich stetig wandelnden erkenntnisse was
bedeutet die omikron variante die zwar
allem anschein nach mildere
krankheitsverläufe bringt sich aber
gesehen dass seine zahlen von heute
deutlich aggressiver ausbreitet was
bedeutet die hoffnung auf ein wirksames
corona medikament und was sind die
motivlagen derer die eine impfung
weiterhin ablehnen wie sollen wir
umgehen mit ihren ängsten und sorgen
wenn wir diese fragen gleich miteinander
diskutieren sozusagen beispielhaft für
die vielen diskussionen in unserem land
dann hoffe ich wir tun es mit werbe aber
auch mit der bereitschaft einander
zuzuhören mit respekt vor anderen
haltungen aber auch mit respekt vor
fakten und vernunft die unsere
gemeinsame währung sein und bleiben
müssen
warum ist das für unsere demokratie so
entscheidend es gibt menschen die sagen
wir haben in deutschland eine corona
diktatur
meine damen und herren das ist
bösartiger unfug denn darin steckt nicht
nur verachtung für unsere demokratischen
rechtsstaatlichen institutionen
sondern darin steckt auch eine
beleidigung von uns allen wir kämpfen
uns monat für monat durch diese pandemie
aber
eben nicht weil wir mit eiserner hand
gelenkt und gesteuert werden sondern
weil die große mehrheit immer wieder
darum ringt das richtige zu tun
verantwortlich zu handeln
solidarisch zu sein weil menschen
überall in den familien im freundeskreis
am arbeitsplatz in den schulen in kitas
in den kliniken und pflegeheimen in den
rathäusern gesundheitsämtern und
parlamenten weil menschen überall dort
miteinander darum ringen was zu tun ist
und genau darum
und dieses demokratische ringen geht es
uns auch hier heute in dieser debatte
meine damen und herren die pandemie ist
nicht vorbei vielleicht lange noch nicht
vorbei aber es wird der tag kommen an
dem sie hinter uns liegt und an diesem
tag werden wir zurückschauen und fragen
was hat die pandemie mit unserer
gesellschaft gemacht hat sie uns
auseinander getrieben
hat sie die gräben weiter vertieft wie
die vielleicht vorher schon angelegt
waren oder
sind wir enger zusammen gerückt weil wir
im rückblick sagen kann wir haben diese
dunkle zeit trotz allem streit trotz
allem schmerz miteinander überwunden
ich bin überzeugt die antwort auf diese
frage entscheidet sich auch an der
debatte die wir heute und in diesen
tagen führen miteinander nicht nur am
jahr oder nein zu einer impfpflicht
sondern an der überzeugungskraft von
guten gründen
an der art und weise wie wir in unserem
land miteinander sprechen und
miteinander umgehen umso dankbarer bin
ich ihnen allen dass sie heute mit
diskutieren und ich persönlich bin
jedenfalls sehr gespannt auf die
nächsten anderthalb bis zwei stunden
herzlichen dank in allen fürs kommen
fürs zuhören fürs mitdiskutieren vielen
dank
ja so weit so wächst die eröffnungsrede
von bundespräsident frank walter
steinmeier bei diesem bürgerdialog zudem
der bundespräsident vor allem
bürgerinnen und bürger eingeladen hat
die sich zuvor in briefen an ihn gewandt
hatten und eben darin erklärt haben
warum sie eine allgemeine impfpflicht
ablehnen beziehungsweise befürworten
auch bürgerinnen und bürger die in ihren
berufen in der pandemie besonders
gefährdet sind etwa aus dem gesundheits
aus dem bildungsbereich zählen zu den
gästen hier im schloss bellevue und nun
also beginnt diese diskussion des
bundespräsidenten mit anwesenden aber
eben wie wir sehen auch zugeschalteten
bürgerinnen und bürgern zum thema
impfpflicht
also herzlichen dank nochmal willkommen
allen danke für ihre bereitschaft heute
morgen mit zu diskutieren es ist klar
worum es geht das habe ich versucht eben
in meinen eingangs bemerkungen zu
beschreiben mich interessiert wie sie
persönlich wie sie im familienkreis im
freundeskreis mit der frage der
allgemeinen impfpflicht umgehen was sind
ihre meinung und ihre hoffnungen ihre
sorgen ihre ängste und ich bin
interessiert
an einen möglichst konstruktiven
austausch in dieser runde und wir wollen
den uns begleitenden journalistinnen und
journalisten sagen
zunächst werden mit diskutiert da ist
zunächst frau sigrid otto
leiterin des seniorenzentrums der
caritas in berlin wir haben zum zweiten
frau ellen chopper dort examinierte
krankenschwester in der
universitätsklinik köln
und wir haben nicht weit er vom bellevue
entfernt den konrektor der hedwig dohm
schule in berlin herrn sven winter
herzlich willkommen auch ihn
am bildschirm sehe ich zugeschaltet aus
der ferne herrn oliver voigt aus baunach
das liegt irgendwo in der nähe von
bamberg habe ich mir sagen lassen wenige
kilometer nördlich von bamberg und sie
sind assistent der geschäftsleitung
genau bei einem importeur für
fahrradzubehör genau richtig und bin
auch ihrem hause der krone auf sagte
dankeschön dann haben wir frau gudrun
gessert aus kirchentellinsfurt
sie sind biologen und
vertretungslehrerin zur zeit am
gymnasium oder mehreren gymnasien in
tübingen und reutlingen und damit wissen
wir auch schon ungefähr wo
kirchentellinsfurt liegt zwischen
tübingen und reutlingen oder jedenfalls
in der nähe davon
wir haben herrn professor kein nagel mit
dem ich auch gleich staaten werde hier
von der technischen universität in
berlin
sie werden sich fragen warum von einer
technischen universität das wird sich
gleich aufklären wenn ich in näher
vorstellen und wir haben frau
professorin cornelia betsch von der
universität erfurt von haus aus
psychologen aber intensiv mit fragen
der
haltung in der bevölkerung zum impfen zu
impfkampagnen und auch zu impfpflicht
befasst ich glaube schon seit ihrer
habilitation beschäftigt sie diese frage
wir freuen uns dass wir in ihrer
expertise heute morgen
teilhaben dürfen ich hatte gesagt wir
wollen staaten mit herrn professor nagel
der professor nagel sie sind von ihrem
fach her zuständig für verkehrssystem
planung und verkehrstelematik
das scheint zunächst so als habe das mit
unserem thema nur wenig zu tun
tatsächlich sind sie aber derjenige
experte der sich schon einen großen
namen gemacht hat bei der untersuchung
des ausbreitung des verhaltens des
corona virus saß kauf 2 sie haben
modelle und modellierungen entwickelt
die damals überzeugt haben ich will
staaten mit der frage
welchen stand der professor nagel
könnten wir nach ihren parametern jetzt
nach zwölf monaten
der kampagne haben könnten wir haben und
welchen stand haben wird tatsächlich
können sie das so beschreiben dass es
auch nicht modellierer verstehen
vielen dank sehr geehrter herr
bundespräsident über anwesende
also ich habe mir ein bisschen überlegt
wie ich das beantworten und ich mir das
jetzt auch nicht so lange machen man
kann ja nachfragen aber was vielleicht
doch hilfreich ist zu sehen dass wir
wählen hatten die von außen gleich
aussehen die aber in ihrer erinnerung
nicht doch auch sehr unterschiedlich
waren unter hilft natürlich auch genau
diese modellierung diese unterschiede zu
erkennen und ein gutes beispiel jetzt
für das was wir jedes goutieren das
recht die del tabelle nicht das war
jetzt november/dezember wo wir sehr
unterschiedliche impfquoten zum beispiel
sachsen und nordrhein westfalen ab
mietwagen um 15 prozentpunkte
auseinander und das resultat was redet
in den statistiken sehen ist dass wir in
sachsen etwa pro woche pro kopf zehn mal
mehr todesfälle haben als in nordrhein
westfalen das heißt also da ist in
gewisser weise der weg gegangen worden
dass mehr leute den weg der in
realisierung über die infektion gewählt
haben als resultat gibt es die
todesfälle und davor muss man halt sehen
dass das eine erhebliche höhere
krankenhaus belastung gab also ein
system und personen die sich engagieren
die arbeit leisten müssen um das
irgendwie zu verarbeiten jetzt haben wir
die omikron welle da haben sie
eigentlich das wesentlich eben schon
gesagt stärker ansteckend
wahrscheinlichen ganze starke verläufe
ob die überforderung jetzt diesmal eher
in den intensivstationen auftritt über
er deswegen wollte ich alle gleichzeitig
krank werden ist noch nicht klar also
wieder eine andere art herausfordern ich
glaube das ist auch wichtig zu sehen
dass das sozusagen nicht nach schema f
rät und auch wenn wir nicht nachdenken
da irgendwo ein update mechanismus mit
drinnen sein muss damit wir eben mit
diesen ganzen veränderungen umgehen
können vielleicht weil das ganz gut
passt gerade auch noch ein paar sachen
zur impfung das gibt dann individuelle
und eine gesellschaftliche sage ich mal
sichtweise das spielt jetzt noch rolle
weil das eben auch zum einen die modelle
treibt und zum anderen auch die
wesentlichen parameter sind um die
individuelle komponente da gibt es eine
risikoabschätzung und ich will das jetzt
hier gar nicht ausbreiten ich kann aber
ich sag mal nachvollziehen dass
insbesondere junge leute zu der
einschätzung kommen dass das risiko der
impfung für sie sagt man nicht
akzeptabel ist vergleichbar mit der mit
dem risiko von der infektion also das
statistische zahlen das kann jetzt um
die anders sehen das ist ein risiko
auswertung das ist ein bisschen wie die
autofahrenden sicherheitscode und mit
dem fahrrad dem auto fahren und so
weiter aber die leute kommen als nach
einschätzung und aufgrund der zahlen ist
insbesondere für jüngere durchaus
nachvollziehbar für mich es gibt aber
noch einmal komponente und zwar ist dass
die sache jetzt mal die
gesellschaftliche die solidarische ein
bisschen moralisch fassen will oder
vielleicht auch einfach externe kosten
und das ist zum einen wenn ich eine
infektion zu lassen und die kann ich
nicht vollständig vermeiden dass
wenigstens versuchen dann entstehen
daraus möglicherweise ketten und
innerhalb dieser ketten gibt es schwere
verläufe und da kann ich halt meinen
beitrag leisten dass nicht das reduziere
das ist recht ein bisschen wie dass ich
mein auto zum tüv bringen und das zweite
ist dass ich jetzt dann in dem fall
jetzt konkret durch eine impfung die
wahrscheinlichkeit eines schweren
verlaufs reduziere und damit eben auch
die leistung des krankenhaus systems und
der leute die da aber durch meine ich
ich glaube das sind so die komponenten
recht eigene risikowahrnehmung aber eben
auch dieser gesellschaftliche beitrag
und gerade dieser gesellschaftlichen
weiter habe ich genau das was in den
simulationen immer wieder drin dass also
die frage wenn man das buch und
erträglich für ein schloss hat das
eigentlich und was hilft uns das und bei
der welt der welle hat man eigentlich
ganz gut gesehen also jetzt aber nur mit
der schnellen muster kampagne und eben
ich sag mal impfquote sachsen versus nrw
wie stark die unterschiede sein können
ja vielen dank zunächst für diese erste
einschätzung
wenn wir sie als modell ihrer fragen wie
wird sich das weiterentwickeln die
impfkampagne der zurückliegenden zwölf
monate ist der vielleicht nicht ganz
einfach zu beschreiben am einfachsten
ist es wahrscheinlich noch zu sagen dass
die impfquote objektiv zu niedrig ist
schon bei der frage ob die impfkampagne
schleppend verläuft kommen wir
eigentlich auf etwas unterschiedliche
auf etwas unterschiedliche antworten wir
sind bei den vollständig geimpften
eindeutig mit gut 70 prozent nicht hoch
genug die booster kampagne läuft
tatsächlich sehr gut wenn sie das
fortschreiben
in die in die steigende bedeutung
dominanz der omicron variante wo werden
wir in wenigen wochen in wenigen monaten
stehen ja das ist irgendwie tatsächlich
sehr differenziert zu betrachten also in
den herbst reihen wäre eine höhere im
sport spricht gewesen das wäre aber auch
hilfreich gewesen früher mit dem ostern
zu beginnen was man in gewisser weise
probiert hätte machen können das haben
wir jetzt sehr viel engagement
ausgeglichen jetzt stellt sich bei
omikron heraus dass das vielleicht über
glück ist weil wir nämlich so spät fuß
dann ist das noch relativ frisch und
hilft jetzt wieder mehr gegen omikron wo
man auch immer sieht wie schwierig das
ist das tatsächlich irgendwo koordiniert
zu steuern also bekommt es glaube ich so
ein bisschen die frage ob man mit dem
blauen auge davon kommen oder nicht also
da ist auf der einen seite halt dass die
dass das jetzt sehr schnell nach oben
geht also wir rechnen im moment mit
einer verdoppelung der insolvenzen pro
woche zumindest da wo
überall vorhanden ist also in berlin und
bremen und haben auch unsere weiter da
sieht man das ja auch mehr oder weniger
man es selber mal mit amtlich
vorschreiben wo das dann relativ schnell
landet dann werden die leute
wahrscheinlich darauf werden in denen
sie vorsichtiger werden dann bremst das
ein bisschen und es gibt da noch
immunisierung auf der anderen seite sind
die krankenhaus verläufe das ist jetzt
eigentlich relativ gar nicht ganz so
schlimm das ist vielleicht eine hälfte
oder drittel so starke belastung pro
infizierte personen die das vorher bei
delta war aber das ist natürlich wenn
wir jede woche verdoppeln ist so eine
verdoppelung relativ schnell
aufgefressen andererseits haben jetzt
einfach eine relativ hohe quote so dass
die die wahrscheinlichkeit der schweren
verläufe kleiner also wie gesagt wir
sind im moment irgendwie zwischen blauem
auge und schlimmer in den vorhersagen
die wir im moment haben
nagl welche beschleunigung der impfquote
oder welche beschleunigung der
impfkampagne sollte ich eher sagen
welche beschleunigung der impfkampagne
halten sie denn eigentlich für
realistisch
wird man ohne die impfquote noch eine
mehrzahl der bisher ungeimpften
erreichen oder
würden sie es so sehen dass man die
impfquote braucht um noch eine deutliche
erhöhung der der impfquote hinzukriegen
eine eine
würde man würde man eine mehrzahl der
ungeimpften erreichen um eine höhere
impfquote hinzukriegen ja also wirklich
der motivation bin ich tatsächlich froh
dass kollegin beach dabei ist die kann
das besser beantworten als ich am rhein
von panini management kann man das im
moment vielleicht auch so sehen dass
jetzt wahrscheinlich sehr viele leute
erreichen wird die nicht geimpft sind
und insofern gibt man kriegt man dann
diese grundimmunisierung durch infektion
ist nicht sehr schön wie ich eben
ausgeführt habe weil es diese relativ
robust fälle hat und da wird jetzt die
schnelle impfung auch nicht mehr sehr
viel dran ändern außer dass natürlich
die leute die jetzt den schutz noch
mitnehmen wollen das schnell machen
sollten weil das halt doch relativ
schnell auch diesen schutz bewirkt also
von daher gesehen bin ich da tatsächlich
ein bisschen unsicher ich glaube es ist
schon wichtig dass wenn wir panini
steuern wollen dass wir uns klarmachen
dass er immer mal wieder angepasst die
impfstoffe brauchen werden und dass wir
da auch über einen akademischen verlauf
hinweg dann werden nach steuern müssen
und das wird halt auch nach unten
bedeuten und auch die bereitschaft dafür
und irgendeine frage wie die impfpflicht
es aufnimmt aber so dir eine
grundimmunisierung
bewegen wir uns in die nähe dass er das
vielleicht jetzt auch durch natürlich
infektion und entsprechend hohe
belastung der intensivstation dann auch
irgendwann erreichen
[Musik]
herr nagel hat schon ob sie verwiesen
sie befassen sich mehr aus verwaltungs
wissenschaftlicher sicht
mit der frage des impfens und deshalb
auch mit
der sinnhaftigkeit oder der
notwendigkeit von impfpflicht
die frage die ich an der nagel gestellt
habe auch an sie gerichtet erreichen wir
mit der impfquote menschen die sich
bisher jedenfalls
den schutz durch impfungen nicht
gewünschte
montag erstmal an alle auch herzlichen
dank von mir für die einladung ich freue
mich dass diese runde gibt und ich
glaube es ist ganz wichtig dass wir den
dialog treten
wir beobachten ja nun die veränderung
der impfbereitschaft schon weg märz und
april letzten jahres und da hat sich
sehr viel getan und man kann sagen dass
unter den leuten die in unseren
befragungen umgesetzt sind die
überwiegende mehrheit eigentlich sagt
ich will mich auf keinen fall impfen
lassen das ist also 60 70 prozent derer
die sagen ich bin um gm und das ist
schon daher eine sehr schwierige frage
wie diese gruppe die ja auch sehr
wichtig ist dafür das einfach diese
familie gestoppt wird oder wir
ihnen wieder ein normaleres leben rein
kommen ob die noch erreicht werden kann
mit anderen methoden
im pflicht es ja auch so was darüber
müssen vielleicht heute auch noch mal
regen was meinen wir damit eigentlich es
gibt ganz unterschiedliche ausgestaltung
jetzt wird ja auch
werden verschiedene politische gruppen
bilden sich und denken sich aus wie kann
sowas ausgestaltet sein ich glaube es
gibt viele möglichkeiten die leute zum
impfen zu bewegen man muss sich als
nachfragen warum sind um wir haben ja
vielleicht heute auch die gelegenheit
das auch noch mal ein bisschen mehr zu
explorieren ich kann da dass unsere
forschung sagen dass sehr viele von den
leuten die sagen ich würde mich auf
keinen fall impfen lassen angst vor dem
guten haben und denken dass eben da
möglicherweise was widerfährt was
vielleicht ihre weise und ich glaube das
sind ganz ist das ganz wichtiges weil
dadurch wird das psychologisch gesehen
eine heiße debatte was emotional das ja
das ist nicht irgendwie ich überlege
pros und cons sondern wenn man angst vor
etwas hat und es droht eine pflicht dann
löst glaube das ist etwas was wir sicher
heute auch noch besprechen werden was ja
wohl sowohl individuell wie auch
gesellschaftlich
schwierig handle weil
sie beteiligen sich federführend an der
cosmo lanz langzeitstudie
in der sie über einen langen zeitraum
untersuchen wie verändert sich zeigen
dass die psychologische lage in einer
gesellschaft was haben sie da an
beobachtungen bisher zum feststellen
können
aber wir sehen schon dass mit den fall
von sich auch die wahrnehmung der panini
verändert sowie nagel das gerade gesagt
vertrauen in die viele steigenden steigt
meine risiko waren die leute werden
wieder etwas vorsichtiger
aber was wir da vor allem wenn jetzt
gerade über das impfen regen beobachten
können als dass leute die geimpft sind
leute die nicht gewillt sind sich auch
in der wahrnehmung der panini sehr stark
unterscheiden also wenn ich umgehen
spinnen dann nehme ich die familie nicht
so stark als risiko war deswegen schütze
ich mich auch nicht so stark ich mache
mir nicht so viele sorgen also es ist
eine sehr andere wahrnehmung als von
leuten die er wie impft sind also das
finde ich sind ganz wichtige einsichten
weil das uns eben auch zeigt dass vieles
in der kommunikation vielleicht bei
manchen leuten gar nicht ankommt oder
einfach anders waage wird sie haben ja
vorhin schon darauf hingewiesen
dass sie auch noch viele andere kreative
ideen hätten wie man auf die
impfbereitschaft von menschen einwirkt
was haben sie da im kopf
so einmal habe ich ja schon gesagt es
gibt viele menschen die um geimpft sind
die angst vor dem hinten haben ich
glaube hier zeigt sich dass von anfang
an ein bisschen versäumt wurde da über
die sicherheit der impfung stärker so
aufzuklären das ist wirklich jeden
erreicht ich glaube diese leerstelle
hier wurde zum teil über bestseller
bücher die man am ende in der guten
supermarktkasse kaufen konnten die sehr
im kritisch waren besetzt und ich glaube
dadurch hat sich viel an
falschinformationen auch an angst
einfach festgesetzt die teilweise eben
auch bewusst geschürt wird von sehr
wenigen ins gegnern da möchte ich auch
gerne die fernsehsender die das hier
glaube ich zum teil auch live übertragen
auch noch mal aufrufen sich dass man
sehr genau anzuschauen also wir brauchen
hier sehr viel mehr aufklärung auch die
regierung ist da
aufgerufen noch mal sehr genau
hinzuschauen wo vorhaben die menschen
eigentlich angst das ist die
wissenschaftliche antwort wie erreicht
sie die menschen wir haben das auch noch
mal sehr umfangreich abgefragt kann ich
gleich schon mal sagen ab freitag gibt
es das auf der kola - monitor punkt.de
seite zum runterladen
welche ängste wir
finden bei menschen die vor dem insel
angst haben und ich glaube hier braucht
es sehr viel aufklärung das ist dass
einer das wird es nicht richten da bin
ich mir mittlerweile auch relativ sicher
wir sehen in der verhaltensforschung in
der psychologie ansätze die zeigen wenn
man das gewünschte verhalten was in dem
fall das impfen ist möglichst einfach
macht dann wird es häufiger gezeigt dazu
gehört zum beispiel dass man
angeschrieben wird dass man einen
impftermin geschickt bekommt dass man
informationen zugeschickt bekommt das
können wir in deutschland nicht machen
weil wir kein system haben so was wie
ich sage jetzt mal ins register oder
elektronische patientenakte wo klar ist
wer als geimpft wird es nicht gehen für
wen ist es vielleicht besonders wichtig
in dänemark wurde man von oben nach
unten vom alter eingeladen und es war
völlig klar wenn man dran ist man musste
sich nicht durchs internet mühlen man
hat einfach einen termin geschickt
bekommen und es war klar es geht nach
alter und relativ gut saniert und ich
glaube hier müssen wir sehr deutlich am
system im gesundheitssystem in
deutschland was ändern dass wir da
einmal die einsicht haben also sollten
wir die impfpflicht brauchen brauchen
wir so machen kriegen dann brauchen wir
so ein system sowieso klar als wäre es
gift und wer es nicht kennt aber es wäre
auch gut für die kommunikation für die
erreichbarkeit der leute damit man wie
auch informieren und eben auch zu
impfungen einladen kann das hat einen
anderen beziehung sehr gut funktioniert
vielen dank für diese einsicht sie sagen
wir müssen uns beschäftigen mit den
sorgen und ängsten auf der einen seite
aber natürlich auch mit den hoffnungen
die andere auf die impfung setzen
forscher dort
die sind krankenschwester habe ich
vorhin gesagt wollen sie uns vielleicht
mal ihre haltung was sie an ängsten aber
möglicherweise auch an hoffnungen mit
der impfung oder sogar mit der
impfpflicht verbinden sagen ja noch ein
herzliches hallo von meiner seite aus
mein name ist ein château des arbeite in
der uniklinik köln und
bin quasi an vorderster front seit
pandemie beginnen mit dem thema
konfrontiert worden
vielleicht ist es wichtig für sie als
hintergrund noch mal zu wissen meine
tätigkeit beinhaltet einen konsul dienst
im gesamten klinikum
wie sie tieren also ganz
unterschiedliche patienten in vielen
fachbereichen und
sind dann natürlich besonders auf den
infektionsschutz dieser variablen
patientengruppe extrem
am 8 und deshalb besonders wichtig dass
wir nicht als pandemie treiber in einer
klinik
[Musik]
möglicherweise aber
stattfinden
für mich es ist extrem wichtig dass
pflegefachkräfte am infektionsschutz
betreiben das ist auch unsere aufgabe
wir sind nach dem
wir sind dazu angehalten nach einem
wissenschaftlichen aktuellen
medizinischen stand patienten zu
versorgen und wenn wir wissen dass
impfungen schwere verläufe letztendlich
reduzieren oder vermeiden dann gehört
das gemisch selbstverständlich auch zu
meiner tätigkeit dass ich mich impfen
lasse
wir haben bei uns in der kliniken
relativ hohen impfstatus sind 97 prozent
der mitarbeiter geimpft und sogar 75
prozent mittlerweile 97 und mittlerweile
auch 75 prozent gebucht hat also wir
waren sehr froh dass wir relativ früh
auch mit einer impfkampagne in der
klinik starten konnten weil uns das
einfach im alltag sehr viel last und
bedenken genommen hat
nicht desto trotz gibt es auch noch
einige wenige mitarbeiter bei uns die
nicht geimpft sind
aber dass die zahl ist wirklich
definitiv verschwindend geringe also
sehr hoher anteil
für die das sehr bedeutend war es ist
sicherlich in schutz für uns als
mitarbeiter aber natürlich auch für die
patienten die wir versorgen wir sind ein
haus der maximalversorgung
betreuen dort patienten die an
schwersten krank sind und
wir möchten dann natürlich auch
infektionen innerhalb der klinik
letztendlich vermeiden ich möchte
natürlich auch meine sozialen kontakte
und hat meine familie davor schützen
insofern ist es für mich einfach
unglaublich starke bedeutung geimpft zu
sein und ein starkes zeichen
in ihren einrichtungen für ihre
einrichtungen hat die politik ja eine
entscheidung getroffen wir laufen zu auf
eine einrichtungs bezogene impfpflicht
wie ist die in ihrer einrichtung von
ihren kolleginnen und kollegen
aufgenommen worden war es überwiegend
die einsicht die bei ihnen zu der hohen
impfquoten geführt wird oder
war die einrichtungs bezogene pflicht
sagen wir mal eine unterstützung oder
förderung der emv bereit ich glaube dass
die
anzahl an wirklichen im zuger lingen
extrem verschwindend gering gewesen ist
natürlich mit der einrichtungs bezogenen
pflicht bleibt ihnen gar nichts anderes
übrig
aber ich denke noch mal das verständnis
ist mittlerweile bei wirklich jedem
angekommen hören sie das auch ähnlich in
ähnlicher weise aus anderen häusern oder
ist die impfquote bei ihnen besonders so
kollegen aus anderen häusern berichten
eigentlich
über
altersheime pflegeheime
haben wir uns in den letzten zwei jahren
viel unterhalten aus ganz
unterschiedlichen gründen erstens
weil es eine hohe anzahl an infektionen
leider auch an todesfällen gab
zweitens weil es während der
einschränkung der besuchsmöglichkeiten
viel menschliches leid gab
sowohl auf der seite der
bewohner und bewohnerinnen von
altersheimen pflegeheimen aber natürlich
auch ganz besonders auch auf der seite
der
angehörigen die ihre eltern und
großeltern nicht besuchen konnten
insofern wissen wir ungefähr wie die
situation sich in den altersheimen
entwickelt hat wir hatten gott sei dank
im letzten herbst eine gewisse
entspannung der situation
und ich weiß dass viele sich gefreut
haben ihre berufstätigkeit wieder
aufzunehmen wie ist die situation heute
bringen
ich muss dazu sagen also bei uns also
wir haben auch eine sehr hohe impfquoten
irgendwie mitarbeiter haben sie sich
wirklich sehr zeitnah auch impfen lassen
das muss man sagen es auch ein privileg
gewesen dass wir uns auch gleich zu
anfang der impfkampagne
wir haben impfen lassen können
die besucher finden wieder eigentlich
oder eingeschränkt statt also es heißt
die besucher müssen sich halt anmelden
sie müssen sich testen dürfen dann aber
auch ihre angehörigen besuchen das hat
sich eigentlich
seit die impfung auch durchgeführt
wurden ziemlich 1
als sie wollen auch sagen bei ihnen war
es eher die einsicht der
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter dass
man einen besonderen verantwortung
verhältnis gegenüber den betreuten steht
die dazu geführt hat dass die impfquote
so hoch ist ich finde mich anschließt es
eigentlich beides auf der einen seite
natürlich auch der schutz für sich
selbst aber auch eben der schutz den
bewohnern bewohnerinnen gegenüber
der winter
die schulen waren ein thema in der
öffentlichen debatte weil es
präsenzunterricht die unterbrechung des
präsents unterrichtes durch digitalen
unterricht gab und vieles andere mehr
eine zeit die schülerinnen und schüler
sehr belastet hat es gab schon einige
die von einer
verlorenen generation gesprochen haben
das halte ich für übertrieben viele der
jugendliche fühlen sich ein wenig
ausgebremst und nicht ausreichend
berücksichtigt aber es war nicht nur
eine extreme belastung für die
schülerinnen und schüler sondern wie wir
wissen auch für für viele eltern gerade
da wo beide elternteile
tagsüber in der arbeit sind war es
extrem schwer den arbeitsalltag zu
organisieren dann abhängig von den
wohnverhältnissen in großen wohnungen es
ist etwas leichter als in kleinwohnungen
das kennen sie alles wie wird bei ihnen
zunächst mal im kollegium über die frage
der impfpflicht diskutiert also ich
denke die meisten kolleginnen und
kollegen sind da sehr offen gegenüber
sie sprachen hier an die den
präsenzunterricht die ins netz wieder
gibt und ich glaube das ist dass die
impfungen eine ganz wichtige ein ganz
wichtiger schlüssel für den
präsenzunterricht auch sind eine
kollegin sagte mir neulich
im prinzip stehe ich ja jede stunde 25
neuen möglichen infektionsträger
gegenüber und ja auch im unterricht ich
sagen wir mal thema abstand halten
lüften gilt ja auch durch die presse
alles nicht so einfach wie man sich das
vorstellt und auch erst einmal abstand
bei den schülern ist immer schwierig
es war auch bei den meisten kolleginnen
und kollegen ganz wichtig dass sie so
schnell wie möglich ihre impfung
bekommen weil einfach auch so ein
bisschen eine eine sicherheit dadurch
besteht vor allem auch falls man
infiziert ist dass der verlauf nicht so
schwer wird als ohne die impfung ich
sehe es jetzt auch dass das auch viele
schüler vermehrt sich jetzt impfen
lassen wollen wo es ja jetzt geht und
ich denke auch dass das ist auch ganz
wichtig ist als schulgemeinschaft wo so
viele leute so vielen anderen leuten
täglich auf engsten raum begegnen dass
man da diesen schutz wahrnimmt
sie haben auch zwischendurch digitale
unterricht gemacht
also der lega unterricht war natürlich
für für alle schwierig ich sag mal als
das alles anfing war das so gefühlt von
von heute auf morgen wir hatten im
prinzip ja zwei tage zeit um uns
umzustellen und die schüler mit erstmal
mit material zu versorgen und dann am
anfang jeder kollege sind ja auch
schülerinnen und schüler die von hause
aus nicht mit dem modernsten technischen
dass das kommt doch rechtsaußen dazu
also wir sind eine schule in besonders
schwieriger lage wo ist nicht
selbstverständlich ist dass jeder
schüler zu hause ist die technisch
ausstellung an hat aber auch ich habe
mal den platz viele familien sind sehr
kinderreich
da ist einmal der platz dass sich jemand
zurückziehen kann und dann in ruhe
lernen kann nicht umhin gegeben das
kommt noch dazu
[Musik]
also im lehrerbereich das haben wir
verstanden überwiegend wird die
notwendigkeit gesehen dass wir uns einer
höheren quote auf welchem weg auch immer
nähern
wie diskutieren die schülerinnen und
schüler das untereinander wenn sie das
wissen
also das was ich mitbekomme
hängt das auch sehr davon ab wie das wie
das im elternhaus natürlich diskutiert
wird also es gibt schüler wo ja wo die
die eltern sehr darauf achten dass halt
so bald es auch möglich ist eine impfung
dieser schüler stattfinden kann und da
sind die die schlemmer ist auch sehr
positiv eingestellt es gibt auch schüler
die die sich gerne impfen lassen wollen
wir hatten werden auch einen vor einigen
wochen oder eine mutter hat eine
möglichkeit dass sich schüler zur
vernehmung anmelden wo dann die eltern
das leider nicht erlaubt haben das gar
nicht dann sehr schade
das ist ja bei ihm mit all ihren leider
so dass das die eltern unterschreiben
müssen und dann gibt es natürlich die
schüler die ich sag mal aus dem
elternhaus dann meinungen auch
übernehmen die das sehr kritisch sehen
also da gibt es eine sehr große mischung
und leider halt auch nicht einen so
großen zuspruch wie das jetzt unter den
kollegen zum beispiel der fall ist
gibt es diskussionen mit der
schulaufsicht im augenblick über die
frage wie man sich einer höheren
impfquote nähert und ob die impfpflicht
dabei eine rolle spielt oder ist das
noch nicht im gespräch das ist noch
nicht im gespräch allerdings ist es auch
so dass
das wir auch eine sehr hohe und quote im
kollegium haben was ich auch so im
gespräch mit mit anderen schulen
mitbekommen habe also die kollegen die
also da ist die relativ hoch
wie sehr bei den schülern also kollegen
wurde das ja auch schon erhoben bei den
schülern haben wir da noch ob mehr
daraus ein bisschen dunkeln das sind
sozusagen auch so ein bisschen die
eindrücke die man mit den gesprächen mit
den klassen dann natürlich gewinnt wenn
man darüber spricht
vielen dank zunächst für diese runde
hier im saal des fonds perdu ich möchte
gerne mich nähern frau geld und herrn
foht sie sind beide dabei weil sie mir
freundlicherweise
briefe geschrieben haben briefe zur
frage der impfquote zur gegenwärtigen
debatte um eine impfpflicht sie beide
legen wert darauf sie gehören nicht zu
dem kreis der schmuggler und anhänger
von verschwörungstheorien
sondern sie gehören eher zu denjenigen
wie sie mir geschrieben haben die frau
professor b statt das eben schon
angedeutet die ihre sorgen und auch ihre
ängste was die impfung angeht frau
gellert wollen sie mal beginnen
ich würde es für sehr wichtig halten
dass wir zunächst mal schluss machen mit
dieser polarisierung zwischen games und
ungeimpft
das hat zunächst einmal sozial eine
enorme sprengkraft ich halte das für
sehr gefährlich für unsere gesellschaft
denn wem nützt das letztendlich
letztendlich treibt das wähler
radikalen rechten oder wie auch immer
radikalisierten parteien zu und ich
finde es auch in der sache schwierig
denn wir sitzen doch alle im selben boot
können doch als gesellschaft die packen
wir gemeinsam überwinden
und es ist ja auch schwierig zu sagen
was heißt er überhaupt vollständig
geimpft zunächst war die rede von zwei
in floß gut jetzt bin ich heute
vollständig geimpft mit zwei endlosen
aber schon morgen gelte ich als
ungeimpft dann braucht man den booster
inzwischen ist die rede von einem
weiteren huster mit einem angepassten
lebensstoff an die omikron variante also
wir müssen uns schon fragen ob wir da
nicht in so einer dauerschleife von
impfen und postern mit immer neu
angepassten sich noch
bemessenen abständen hineingeraten
aber frau geld ist es nicht ein
vergleichsweise normaler vorgang dass
ich bei einem neu entdeckten virus die
erkenntnislage in der wissenschaft und
medizinischen forschung sich auch
verändert und denn die erkenntnisse
besser werden dass man dann auch die
die impfstoffe verbessert ist das nicht
ein völlig normaler vorgang es ist nicht
nur normal sondern das ist richtig und
wichtig das muss so sein nur
bezogen auf eine impfpflicht halt ich's
dann doch für problematisch eine pflicht
auszusprechen in einem moment wo man gar
nicht genug erkenntnisse hat um zu sagen
so und zu viele impfdosen zu viele uster
in
wie auch immer gearteten abständen weiß
man alles nicht
der nächste punkt
wir haben befürchtet es käme zu einer
pandemie der ungeimpften
das hat sich so in dieser form nicht
bewahrheitet
im herbst über wurde in den medien sehr
oft wiederholt dass die
intensivstationen der kliniken
überfüllt seien mit ungeimpften
aber dazu gab es keine belastbaren
zahlen
der präsident der ddr professor dr
gernot marx sagte noch mittel november
im bundestag ich zitiere
bisher sei noch nicht erfasst welche
patienten auf den intensivstationen
games und welche nicht geimpft sein
ein weiteres argument weshalb
es keine panik wieder um gästen blieb
ist
wenn wir die über 60-jährigen
intensivpatienten anschauen
dann sind da von mitte dezember nach den
offiziellen zahlen des rk nie
wirklich prozent im flur sprüche gewesen
und wenn wir alle über 60-jährigen
hospitalisierten anschauen also nicht
nur die intensivpatienten sondern alle
dann waren es sogar 50 prozent durch
ein weiteres beispiel bremen
liegt die geiseln folge dass ich
unterbreche wird das ist ja kein
argument gegen die impfung das ist
allenfalls ein hinweis das ist
bedauerlich ist dass entgegen manchen
erwartungen zu beginn im durchbrüche
gibt wir hatten gehofft dass das nicht
der fall ist also die wissenschaft hatte
gehofft aber es ist ja kein argument
gegen das impfen ist verstehe ich nicht
und ich bin ja auch nicht gegen das in
ganz und gar sind sie persönlich
gefallen sind sie persönlich
ja wie ich schon ein ganz sagte ich
finde wir müssen aufhören darüber zu
diskutieren ob frau xy geimpft ist oder
nicht bleibt
nicht bei zu einer konstruktiven debatte
sondern wir müssen uns fragen können
wir mit einer impfpflicht die pandemie
besser überwinden als ohne ihn pflichten
oder ist meine these die ich jetzt
einfach mal hier in den raum stellen
möchte
nein die impfpflicht ist nicht geeignet
um die pandemie überwinden zu können ich
sag noch mal ganz kurz meine gründe ohne
das jetzt sagen sie
eine impfpflicht ist problematisch für
die gesellschaft dabei signalisiert
sie ist sozial ungerecht und
möglicherweise sogar unwirksam denn wie
soll sie den durchgesetzt werden mit
bußgeldern wo dann sozial schwächer
gestellte benachteiligt sind und
finanziell besser gestellte das einfach
wegstecken
was macht man mit leuten die sich trotz
bußgeld nicht impfen lassen auch nicht
bezahlen
unser oberbürgermeister
von tübingen hier der boris palmer hat
eine beugehaft ins gespräch gebracht
solche dinge sind für mich
paradebeispiele für
eine debatte ohne jedes maß und ziel das
finde ich erschreckend
und mein letzter punkt das ist mir der
wichtigste
meine meinung ist dass eine impfpflicht
medizinisch in keinem fall vertretbar
wäre ich stelle es jetzt hier so in den
raum ich bin nachher gerne bereit das
weiter auszuführen und zu begründen wenn
es gewünscht wird wird es für mich ein
ganz zentraler punkt die impfpflicht ist
medizinisch nicht vertretbar impfen ja
zwei nein ich plädiere er für eine freie
in fans steigen
sagen sie vielleicht noch mal was zu
ihrem persönlichen verhalten ich
respektiere dass sie sagen wir
sollten die gesellschaft nicht allein an
der frage unterscheiden gehören sie zu
den geimpften oder nicht geimpften aber
was mich persönlich interessiert haben
sie persönlich angst und sorgen was die
impfung angeht und hängt das zusammen
mit den von ihnen eben noch nicht
ausgeführten
sorgen um
ausreichende forschungsergebnisse oder
ausreichende studien oder womit hängt
ihr persönlicher vor wald zusammen
die pandemie mit ihrer gefährdungslage
sehr ernst nehme ich leugne corona
keineswegs ich halte mich an alle
maßnahmen wie a-ha regeln cetera
[Musik]
ich bin auch sehr gerne bereit mich in
zuzulassen in dem moment wo klar ist
dass ich damit mich und andere schütze
aber wozu ich nicht bereit bin
ist die von mir als dauerschleife
bezeichnete situation
dass ich heute noch geimpft bin und
schon morgen als ungeimpft gelte und
dann noch mal und noch mal und noch mal
ohne dass das
[Musik]
medizinisch
abgesichert ist mit daten und fakten
bobic ich glaube sie sind in mehrfacher
hinsicht angesprochen was wissen wir
über die nebenwirkungen von impfungen
was können sie kommentieren wenn der
vorwurf erhoben wird das hier nicht
ausreichend forschung betrieben worden
ist das möglicherweise nicht genügend
studien über die möglichen folgen und
nebenwirkungen von impfungen
vorhanden sind
ja erst mal frau geht es hat vielen dank
für ihre offenheit hier dass sie das
teilen ich hätte glaube ich bevor ich da
noch ein paar sachen zu sagen würde mich
noch mal interessieren wie haben
wichtiges gesagt wir kommen nur
gemeinsam aus dieser pandemie rauskommen
die sagen hier soll sich freiwillig
impfen jetzt haben wir vorhin schon
gesagt dass unter denen die umwelt sind
die wollen eigentlich auch nicht mehr
und wir stellen fest es reicht halt so
nicht wir sitzen jetzt wieder in einem
winter wo wir irgendwie und ich habe
zwei teenager ich war mit denen schon
ewigen kino oder shoppen weil wir
versuchen unsere kontakte zu reduzieren
obwohl wir alle begeistert sind
es ist super frustrierend und die frage
polarisierung der diskriminierung und so
weiter können wir gleich zu besprechen
aber ich würde einfach noch mal aus
ihrer warte interessieren wie kommen wir
denn dann gemeinsam hier raus
wenn wir jeden es selbst überlassen ob
er sich impfen lässt oder nicht das sind
sehr offen gemeinte frage frau doktor
wird das ist eine sehr gute frage ich
glaube das ist die zentrale frage wenn
irgendjemand eine antwort hätte dann
ging es uns allen viel besser ich denke
da gibt es kein patentrezept aber die
impfung ist es leider auch nicht die
impfung hat leider die großen hoffnungen
die wir alle in sie gesetzt habe bislang
nicht erfüllen können war leider nicht
der game changer denn sonst wären wir
doch mich in der situation in der wir
aktuell sind wie gesagt bremen hat eine
impfquote von über 100 prozent und ist
gleichzeitig der spitzenreiter der
insolvenzen in deutschland
dänemark hat eine impfquote die weitaus
höher liegt als in deutschland und hat
aber in grenzen von über 2000 das zeigt
doch dass auch die impfung nicht
das patentrezept ca
also wenn man jetzt sie danke
natürlich haben wir jetzt das gerade mit
einem virus zu tun wer sich extrem
weiterentwickelt rast und
der kommt so ein bisschen um die
impfungen drum rum aber trotzdem es
heißt ja nicht dass die impfung nicht
wirkt es fragt sich wirklich dass die
dass die dreifach impfung deswegen ist
der booster jetzt so wichtig dass der
wirklich hospitalisierung tut gut nach
unten drücken kann deswegen ist es
tatsächlich auch jetzt wo es vielleicht
kein perfekten match mehr gibt zwischen
dem stoff und virus trotzdem wichtig
sich impfen zu lassen und zwar am besten
dreimal
ich glaube sie haben wichtige sachen
angesprochen wird die impfpflicht sowas
tun wie die leute radikalisieren
polarisieren was wir da sie haben auch
den zuspruch von
radikale für radikale parteien
angesprochen ich glaube das ist etwas
was man beobachten kann das
extreme gruppen auch politische gruppen
sich den unmut der leute der entsteht
mit auch mit der regierung da passiert
nichts was die leute nicht wollen
den sich zu nutze machen und dann
anfangen diese gruppen zu unterwandern
wir haben gesagt einer unserer aktuellen
studien gefunden dass die quellen auf
denen sich die leute informieren
bei den leuten die um geimpft sind
tatsächlich andere sind als berlin.de
pfingsten die belastung zum beispiel
viel mehr social media und messenger
programme also so wie man sich das
eigentlich vielleicht sogar vorstellen
und da muss man glaube ich sehr klar
sagen da muss jeder aufpassen mit wem er
marschieren geht mit wem er
demonstrieren geht dass ich das nicht
unterwandert das ist auch jedes
einzelnen verantwortung man kann es
nicht wollen sich impfen zu lassen das
heißt nicht dass ich da alle
radikalisieren aber dass das auch
bewusst betrieben dass das eine und wir
sehen auf der anderen seite dass sowohl
die geimpften als auch die ungeimpften
ich packte jetzt immer in töpfe weil wir
noch impfstatus in unseren studien die
leute vergleichen aber deswegen klingt
das jetzt ein bisschen polarisierte als
das vielleicht eigentlich soll aber wir
wollen ja verstehen was die leute
antreibt also was wiedersehen ist dass
sowohl die leute geimpft sind als auch
die nicht geimpften sich sehr stark mit
ihrem status identifizieren
und die ketten auch mehr leute die so
sind wie sie also die in der geimpften
die ungeimpften denke auch dass die
anderen mit denen sie sich so umgeben so
sind und das führt zu so einer gruppen
diskriminierung also dass das führt
einfach ganz auf natürliche weise dazu
und ich glaube was wir sehen ist
dass die
wissenschaftskommunikation
gesundheitskommunikation hier extrem
wichtig ist und hier viel zu wenig
passiert ist sie sagen selber es rasant
wie sich die dinge ändern erst wird der
impfstoff so lange kämpfen und dann mehr
und so weiter und dass dieses wissen
dann muss natürlich die gesamte
bevölkerung mitgenommen werden und wir
sind pandemie nicht jeder freut sich
irgendwann sich wieder in zu informieren
und hier brauchen wir einfach noch mal
neue art wie informiert wird also sind
ganz viele verschiedene bausteine und
baustellen sind gruppenprozesse die dazu
beitragen dass diskriminierung passiert
ist es mangelhafte
gesundheitskommunikation die am ende
nicht gegen erreicht also es ist ein
sehr komplexes geflecht was wir hier
sehen
dafür haben wir eben noch stellung
nehmen
damit ich halte ihr konzept mit den
tatzen für ein bisschen problematisch
denn das fluktuiert doch
es gibt doch nicht die geimpften und
ungeimpften sondern wir nicht gewusst
hat ist jedoch momentan schon beinahe
wieder als umgehen und ich denke es gibt
auch immer mehr leute die dann sagen
also jetzt habe ich mich zweimal impfen
lassen ostern impfen lassen jetzt
reicht's aber und ich glaube das
spiegelt sich auch in den wachsenden
protesten in diesen sogenannten
spaziergängen und was dann noch an
aktionen mehr gibt und lernten uns an
einmal geehrt verso s gar nicht nur die
bereiche zu ende führen ja
sie haben was ganz wichtiges gesagt dass
wir aufpassen müssen mit wem wir uns
solidarisieren und das geht natürlich
nicht nur an leute die die
protestierenden skeptisch sind nein das
geht an uns alle um das geht vor allem
an die politik was mich so erschreckt
hat herr gysi sagte im zdf vor kurzem 30
prozent der wähler hätten das vertrauen
in die politik verloren
ich weiß nicht woher diese diese zahlen
nimmt aber ich bin erschrocken als ich
das gehört habe das hat doch eine enorme
sprengkraft dann müssen wir auf alle
aufpassen
und die ist das bei ihnen persönlich
haben sie vertrauen in politik verloren
innerhalb dieser letzten zwei jahre
oder besser gesagt
ist die debatte über die impfpflicht ist
die impfkampagne ist es für sie ein
gesichtspunkt an politik zu zweifeln
ich würde sagen ich habe mich in den
zwei jahren noch ein bisschen stärker
politisiert ich habe versucht mich noch
ein bisschen mehr einzubringen eben auch
in dem ich an sie und auch
regierungsvertreter geschrieben habe und
den dialog gesucht habe
vertrauen verloren dass es mir zu
pauschal
nein
weil ich kein vertrauen habe ist in die
impfkampagne in der form wie sie abläuft
da habe ich gar kein vertrauen denn in
meinen augen ist das kein kleiner pieks
und auch kein rettender peace sondern
eine impfung ist eine hoch wirksame
medizinische intervention wird eine
stark reaktor jene substanz injiziert
die dann im körper wirkungen entfaltet
und zwar
irreversibel und
dass man jetzt eine impfkampagne fährt
wo
natürlich notwendigerweise die schnelle
durchimpfung der ganzen bevölkerung im
vordergrund steht das muss so sein aber
wo dann doch individuelle schutz aspekte
vielleicht auf der strecke bleiben
beispiel impfung im shopping center oder
info
sportvereinen ums leben bei
in so etwas habe ich kein vertrauen eine
impfung
die hat zu erfolgen nach eingehender
beratung durch einen arzt und auch in
enger begleitung mit nachbetreuung durch
einen arzt da wären wir wieder beim
stichworten nebenwirkungen was wird denn
überhaupt erfasst von potenziellen
nebenwirkungen wenn sich jemand neben
bayer impfen lassen und es dann gar
nicht zuordnen kann falls er danach aber
frau geistert sie haben doch
verschiedene angebote sie müssen sicher
nicht im sportverein und sie müssen sich
nicht impfen lassen sie können ja auch
in einen impfzentrum oder zu ihrem
hausarzt gehen sich beraten lassen vor
der impfung nach der impfung es ist ja
nicht so dass sie auf die aus ihrer
sicht schlechteren oder weniger
verlässlichen möglichkeiten angewiesen
wären das ist richtig und das werde ich
natürlich auch so machen
selbstverständlich aber sie hatten mich
nach einem vertrauens
und meine antwort war diese weil ich
eben in die impfkampagne kein vertrauen
habe so wie sie angelegt ist und weil
ich auch kein vertrauen habe in die art
wie mit
potenziellen nebenwirkungen umgegangen
herr nagel wenn ich sie nochmal
ansprechen darf august hat etwas gesagt
dass mir in den letzten tagen und wochen
immer häufiger vorkommt ich sag mal
etwas abstrakter der hinweis darauf dass
es offenbar keine korrelation zwischen
der impfquote und der gegenwärtigen
inzidenz gibt ich vermute mal das hängt
damit zusammen dass die erhoffte
schutzwirkung nach der zweiten impfung
gegen omikron nicht in dem umfang da ist
die frage ist nur
welches welche konsequenz ergibt sich
daraus denn wir haben vor der omicron
variante eine dominante variante mit der
delta variante gehabt und man wird ja
wahrscheinlich nicht zurückschauen
können und sagen weil die zwei impfungen
nicht gegen omikron wirkt oder nicht
ausreichend wirkt deshalb war auch die
impfung gegenüber der delta variante
schon unsinnig oder
nicht notwendig das vermutlich wird man
diese schlussfolgerungen hier nicht
ziehen können wir das können sie genauer
erklären
ja so auf keinen fall also ich würde das
vielleicht auch durch aussagen wollen
das vbs hat vieles sagt was glaube ich
ein gang in diese diskussion finden muss
so zeigen auch in dem sinne wie sie das
jetzt gesagt haben nämlich wir müssen
uns überlegen was in den pflicht
eigentlich meinen main wer eine
grundimmunisierung das heißt also es
gibt irgendwie eine absehbare anzahl von
impfung und danach ist schluss oder
schließt das ein dass der regelmäßige
updates auch wenn wir regelmäßige
updates ich sag mal wollen da gibt es ja
die grippeimpfung wo das jetzt auch
nicht so unnormal ist das heißt es gibt
beispiele aber dadurch dass natürlich
genau ohne pflicht sondern das ist
freiwillig angeboten wird aber es ist
jetzt nicht so unwahrscheinlich dass das
erste mal sinnvoll das verfahren ist ein
paar jahre bis wir da eine bessere idee
haben wie das funktioniert also lasst
uns sagen in die andere richtung die
andere richtung diese sache mit dem game
changer nicht also bei delta war es
tatsächlich der game changer biomicro
ist es jetzt in bezug auf die inzidenz
nicht mehr in bezug auf die schweren
verläufe aber sehr wohl wobei die
änderung mit sich der schwere verläufe
das ist ein faktor für etwa 18 in
manchen studien welche sind das
verhindert jetzt auch nicht alle
schweren falles aber dort sehr viele
also man hat bei diesen städten sind
daneben auch häufig 20 prozent um gm
stück produzieren weil es nicht 50 60 70
prozent der patienten auf den
intensivstationen also dass vergibt aber
es ist nicht so dass das jetzt der ein
game changer ist ein baustein und ich
glaube so muss man das auch eben
behandeln und im sinne dieses baustein
sind das war jetzt glaube ich
hoffentlich auch die antwort auf die
omikron frage ist natürlich jetzt die
frage also sie haben eben gesagt das ist
medizinisch nicht vertretbar mit den
impfungen aber die frage hier ist ja
sozusagen wie hoch wird diesen solider
aspekt gewichten wollen also das
sozusagen die impfung die für mich
persönlich vielleicht oder zumindest in
meiner risiko einschätzen daher bietet
wie weit wir wollen dass leute im großen
beitrag diesen diesem solidarbeitrag
leistet und wie man halt dahin kommen
dass möglichst viele stone und das ist
natürlich irgendwie richtig möglichst
nicht gegen ihren eigenen willen oder
ich glaube nicht gegen einen bilden
fertig so ein bisschen ein problem an
der stelle mit dem begriff
solidarbeitrag denn es ist ja so dass
auch vollständig geimpfte das sogar
gepostete das virus weiter gehen können
ja aber schwächer doch für die wir
momentan haben erzeugen keine sterile
immunität eine herren immunität ist
nicht erreichbar das ist mittlerweile
wissenschaftlicher konsens ja ich würde
gerne einen beitrag leisten zur
überwindung der pandemie aber
ich sehe nicht dass das der fall ist
durch simple wenn ich dennoch menschen
weiter infizieren kann als fördere nicht
geimpfte also ich kann das nur noch mal
versuchen so zu sagen ich bin älter war
tatsächlich die reduktion der
transmission erheblich das heißt also da
hat man als die erste person einen
entsprechenden beitrag geleistet micron
ist das kleine aber immer noch vorhanden
das zweite ist dass man einen beitrag
leisten zur reduktion der belastung der
krankenhäuser und das ist immer wieder
nötig sagen jetzt die realität das ist
das leck ist es ein spiel mit
wahrscheinlichkeit mehr also ist es wie
beim autofahren wenn sie eine
funktionierende bremsen haben wird die
wahrscheinlichkeit des unfalls reduziert
aber sind natürlich immer noch da und
vielleicht ist das auch um das guter
vergleich
ich würde sogar noch ein stück weiter
gehen ich würde sogar noch sagen das ist
ein bisschen gefährlich ist wenn man den
leuten suggeriert lasst euch insel
schützt euch schützt andere ich werde
man müsste sogar ein bewusstsein dafür
schaffen dass dieser schutz eben nicht
absolut sicher ist wir haben das
beispielsweise hier in baden württemberg
schmerzen da müssen wir hatten von
anfang an sehr strenge maßnahmen unser
ministerpräsident winfried kretschmann
ist da sehr konsequent wir hatten schon
seit langer zeit konsequent zweig
[Musik]
ungeübte waren schon recht früh an der
sozialen teilhabe nur noch reduziert
dabei
und was wir beobachten konnten zwar dass
die zahlen auch hier in baden wird über
explodiert sind mit delta weil eben die
menschen geglaubt haben ja ich bin
geimpft mir kann nichts passieren
wir sind zu 2g veranstaltungen gegangen
das waren teilweise große
veranstaltungen stichwort fußball
und dort wurde die infektion
weitergegeben darin sehe ich eine gefahr
es war kein argument gegen das impfen
sondern ist eher ein argument dafür wenn
auch dass auch die diejenigen die
geimpft sind weitere verhaltensmaßnahmen
einhalten richtig herr bundespräsident
ich bin nicht gegen das impfen das ist
eine richtige wichtige und notwendige
maßnahme um die pandemie zu überwinden
das steht außer frage aber wir müssen
damit richtig umgehen
klaren darüber sein dass uns die
impfungen nicht
absolute sicherheit gibt dass hier auch
als jenes spiel weiterhin vorsichtig
sein müssen weiterhin das virus
übertragen können ich glaube da wird
ihnen hier in der runde niemand
widersprechen herfurth sie haben wir
noch nicht gehört ich habe schon gesagt
sie sind mitarbeiter in einem
speditionsunternehmen in bamberg haben
wahrscheinlich viel kundenkontakt und
deshalb würde sie ganz gerne fragen was
ist zunächst mal ihr ganz persönliches
motiv
sich so stark gegen ich weiß nicht sagen
sie es selbst gegen die impfung oder
gegen die impfpflicht auszusprechen
erstmalig einen dank der bundespräsident
für die eintragung meine damen und
herren ich
möchte mich in keinster weise gegen die
die impfung aussprechen jedoch die den
impfzwang die impfpflicht sehe ich als
problematisch ich würde gerne text
vorbereiter zu leben den ich vorbereitet
habe und vielleicht kommentare über
jahren in die diskussionen bei einem
verständnis die bevölkerung für eine
impfbereitschaft zugewinn halte ich es
für unmoralisch bei den erkenntnissen
die wir zur verfügung stehenden dem
stoffe haben den menschen eine
impfpflicht bzw ein impfzwang durch
verordnung aufzuerlegen bei den
bestrebungen bleibende
gesundheitszustände der einzelnen
menschen die wirksamkeit der eben stoffe
und die nebenwirkungen der impfstoffe
völlig unberücksichtigt
das möchte ich gern begründen erstens
körperliche unversehrtheit jeder mensch
hat das recht auf körperliche
unversehrtheit
und soll frei über eine medizinische
anwendung entscheiden können das recht
auf körperliche unversehrtheit ist von
großer bedeutung da er auch in den
grundrechten fahren hat zweitens
wirksamkeit die wirksamkeit der zur
verfügung stehenden impfstoffe des
höchst fragwürdig dauer der wirksamkeit
die dauer der wirksamkeit ist mit
wenigen monaten mit monaten sehr
kurzfristig b
eingeschränkte schutzwirkung vor der
erkrankung selbst die zahllosen fälle
ankunft durchdrücken zeigen dass die
impfstoffe keinen ausreichenden schutz
vor der erkrankung bieten sie keine
sterile immunität die impfstoffe
verhindern die weiterverbreitung des
virus nicht geimpfte können das virus
weiter geben drittens risiken risiken
bleiben unberücksichtigt
blutgerinnungsstörungen thrombosen
lungenembolien
herzerkrankung
autoimmunreaktion schüttelfrost fieber
sogar todesfälle treten neben weiteren
nebenwirkungen auf
langzeiteffekte sind hier auch gar nicht
berücksichtigt wird und nicht
zugelassene hilfsmittel in den
impfstoffen sind mit lc 03 15
vom amc 0 1 592 hilfsmittel enthalten
welche nicht für die menschliche
anwendung zugelassen sind ich zitiere
aus den angaben des herstellers nur für
forschungszwecke und laboruntersuchungen
nicht für die anwendung am oder im
menschen
unzureichende erkenntnisse du bist ein
impfstoff zugelassen wird dauert es
normalerweise acht bis 17 jahre dieser
meine zeitraum ist auch notwendig jungs
die erfahrung zum beispiel in bezug auf
astra zenica
blutgerinnungsstörung moderner keine
impfung bei unter 30 jährigen und
johnson & johnson todesfälle zeigen
nachdem diese in stoffe bereits ein
viertel beziehungsweise ein halbes jahr
verabreicht wurden wechsel zur option
wichtige weitere option im anime
management prävention medikamentöse
unterstützung in therapie folgen sind
bislang vernachlässigt worden und
sollten ausgebaut werden bei einer
impfpflicht und damit eine
zwangsmedikation ist die gesundheit 1000
bürger 1000 bürgerinnen und bürger
gefährdet wir dürfen nicht den gleichen
fehler machen wie bei der schweinegrippe
im jahr 2009 aufgrund der damaligen info
sind viele menschen an narkolepsie
erkrankt die diskussion wer geimpft ist
und wenn nicht jetzt ist ist zudem nicht
zielführend wir müssen wissen wer
erkrankt ist der virus verbreitet ist
und wer es gesund ist und bei den
erkrankten muss man den mit einem
schweren verlauf helfen
beispielhaft hierfür sind die testung an
schulen es werden alle getestet
unabhängig davon ob dem chinesen oder
nicht geht und dadurch dass man in der
lage frühzeitig maßnahmen zu ergreifen
wer 40 entscheidet sich impfen zu lassen
soll das tun können die entscheidung
muss aber frei sein
vielen vielen dank für ihren text vbz
vielleicht um das schwer gewichtigsten
argumente mal herauszunehmen
die schwerwiegenden folgen
beziehungsweise
todesfällen das müssen wir glaube ich
mal in einer relation
zu den tatsächlich erfolgten impfungen
setzen wir haben etwa 74 millionen 75
millionen impfungen in deutschland wir
haben meldungen
das ist eine größenordnung von
0,01 prozent von
festgestellten neben folgen wobei wir
glaube ich noch keine bestätigung haben
dafür was unmittelbar auf die impfung
zurückzuführen ist aber das können sie
wahrscheinlich genauer sagen
leider in dem fall auch nicht ich glaube
da während mediziner jetzt wird er
gefragt das ist ja alles beim
paul-ehrlich-institut frau geht sie
hatten ja wohl auch gesagt wir werden
nebenwirkungen eigentlich nach verfolgt
also selbst wenn sie sich in der
turnhalle impfen lassen dann können sie
bei jedem arzt jedes verpflichtet und
sie selber kommt es auch zu
nebenwirkungen melden beim
paul-ehrlich-institut und die werden
nach verfolgt und das ist ein sehr
akribischer prozess und wo er gerade
schon gesagt die sind vielleicht noch
nicht zu ende nach verfolgt dieses
natürlich auch medizinische
herausforderung hier in der kausalität
nachzuweisen aber das wird gemacht und
dann wird sehr sehr sehr ordentlich
gearbeitet ich glaube das was wir uns
hier immer klar machen müssen ist erst
mal wie viele leute sind denn jetzt
schon geimpft die hatten gerade die zahl
in deutschland genommen die weltweit
haben schon über vier milliarden
menschen infolge kriegt acht milliarden
dosen
wahrscheinlich sind mittlerweile noch
mehr alles was sehr sehr selten auftritt
ist jetzt bekannt und gerade die ich
glaube wir müssen uns klar machen sie
damals gesagt und moderner nicht für
unter 30 oder hier wird jetzt auch auf
wahnsinnig kann nicht mehr benutzt wir
wissen was jetzt über
herzmuskelerkrankung das sind alles sehr
seltene sache über die wir jetzt
bescheid wissen und wo auch darauf
reagiert wird also mir persönlich
verschafft dass er vertrauen weil ich
weiß da guckt jemand hin es ist
aufgetreten es ist klar es ist eine
medizinische intervention die soll was
schlimmes verhindern das tut sie auch ja
also vor allem krankenhausaufenthalte
tod aber auch ganz gut so symptomatische
erkrankungen man muss ja immer gucken
was verhindert die impfung muss man
unterscheiden zwischen die übertragungen
die ansteckung symptome krankenhaus tod
und gerade die hinteren schlimmeren
dinge da ist die impfung ziemlich gut
und das gegenüber zu stellen gegen die
nebenwirkung dass es wichtig ist sagt ja
auch keiner dass nie irgendwas auftritt
das wäre cool ist und wer auch gelogen
er ist ein risiko das ich sehe ich
vollkommen genauso man muss das risiko
abwägen halten welchen nutzen habe ich
welche risiken habe und dass wie ich
eben halt bei jedem bürger und bei jeder
bürger und selbst weil ich muss eben in
absprache mit meinem arzt muss ich für
mich entscheiden wie es mein
gesundheitszustand
ich sage man übertrieben traue ich mir
in dem punkt zu oder traurig eben mir
keine impfung zu und das obliege eben
jedem einzelnen bürger und jede bürgerin
ich sehe es als doch eine
anführungszeichen große gefahr wenn ich
jetzt wirklich diesen großen deckmantel
über ganz deutschland mache und sage
heben ihr müsst euch alle impfen lassen
ich glaube
planer erkrankung noch relativ viele
menschen wo man hätte vermeiden können
und wenn ich alleine in meinem
persönlichen umfeld sehe werde wer alles
nebenwirkungen hatten da ist zum
beispiel einmal ein fall
wobei der erste bei zweiten impfung
jeweils herz rhythmus störungen
aufgetreten sind dann bei einem des öoc
adidas aufgetreten und ich habe sogar
ein fall in meinem umfeld wurden
verbindung der auffrischungsimpfung
verbindung mit der normalen
grippeimpfung letztendlich sogar jemand
verstorben ist und deswegen bin ich der
ansicht muss es jeder alleine für sich
entscheiden lasse ich mich impfen oder
eben nicht entscheide ich mich dagegen
wobei frau bis eben noch mal in
erinnerung gerufen hat das bei allen
nebenwirkungen die gemeldet werden
sorgfältig untersucht werden muss ob es
eine kausalität zwischen einer
festgestellten erkrankung und der
impfung gibt
dem wird in deutschland klagt dass
frau gessert vielleicht nach ich anders
stell dir nochmal ein haben und das
ganze noch ein bisschen durch fakten und
zahlen materialien der mauern denn wir
wollen hier auf einer sachlichen ebene
diskutieren ich habe mir mal ein paar
zahlen rausgesucht gehe ich gar nicht
kurz nennen würde
bis zum ersten januar diesen jahres sind
bei der ema
verdachtsfälle gemeldet worden
und wenn wir das jetzt mal vergleichen
mit der grippeimpfung
dann sieht man das bei den
verdachtsfällen
für tot
ein faktor
37 herauskommt das heißt es gibt 37 mal
mehr verdachtsfälle wurden gemeldet
für einen tod nach der korona impfung im
vergleich zur capitan funkt und wenn wir
jetzt die bleibenden schäden anschauen
dann ist der faktor sogar bei
und was die erfassung angeht wo sie
sagten frau professorin
das beruhigt sie
mich beruhigt das nicht ich hab da
beispielsweise die aussage von herrn
peter schirmacher im kopf dem direktor
des pathologischen instituts in
heidelberg wir haben bei einer hohen
dunkelziffer nimmt oben weil er einfach
sagt
die pathologen bekämen von vielen
todesfällen gar nichts mit weil da kein
zusammenhang hergestellt wird weil ja
gar keine obduktion angeordnet wird
und wir müssen jetzt auch gar nicht so
weit gehen hier von todesfällen vom
schlimmsten fall sprechen nein das
betrifft auch die nebenwirkungen
ich denke vieles wird einfach nicht
erfasst weil es die leute nicht der in
funktion
ja ich glaube eher dass das gegenteil
der fall ist dass vieles an
unwohlsein und krankheiten der impfung
zugeführt wird und viel zu wenig danach
gefragt wird wo besteht die kausalität
zwischen der impfung und dem was an
unwohlsein und krankheit tatsächlich
auftritt frau
wollte nur eine sache sagen zu den
verdachtsfällen weil wir nicht so
richtig bewusst ist wie dieses system
funktioniert also sie reden jetzt genau
richtig von verdachtsfällen was heißt
das also überall da wo jemand den
verdacht dass entweder der bürger selbst
oder ein arzt es könnte mit der impfung
zusammenhängen dann wird es gemeldet und
das ist natürlich ein sehr niedrige
hürde sag ich mal sie können also beim
paul-ehrlich-institut in einer datenbank
nach gucken was es für verdachtsfälle
gibt und das ist noch nicht geprüft das
ist einfach nur der verdacht warum ist
das so das ist so weil man sagt wir
nehmen alles an signalen was sie spielt
damit wir als was auftritt ganz selten
es sofort sehen können das heißt es wird
permanent im monitor was da an
verdachtsfällen los ist vieles davon
hängt wahrscheinlich überhaupt nicht mit
der info zusammen das wird nach versuch
untersucht das ist ein komplizierter
prozess aber deswegen muss man sehr klar
unterscheiden sind es nebenwirkungen die
aufgetreten sind oder verdachtsfälle
deswegen würde ich immer vorsichtig sein
angesagt ist dann sophie verdachtsfälle
gemeldet
ich will das nicht schmälern ja also ich
will natürlich gibt es neben natürlich
gibt es neben wirkung aber es gibt man
muss es trotzdem ein bisschen einfangen
und quasi sehen als das was sie sind
erst mal verdachtsfälle jeder melden
kann
professor richter ist ganz genau richtig
und das war auch der grund dass ich den
vergleich hergestellt habe zur ritterin
bei der grippeimpfung ist es ja genauso
da handelt es sich ebenfalls um
verdachtsfälle und wenn wir jetzt die
verdachtsfälle bei den corona impfungen
vergleichen mit den verdachtsfällen bei
der griff dann ergibt sich doch ein sehr
eklatanter unterschied und faktor 37 bzw
112 es ist absolut gesehen auch viel
mehr und corinna impfungen als griff
aber
niedriger freund gesagt das ist ja nicht
der eigenen der einzige abwägungs
gesichtspunkt mit dem sie befasst sind
sondern sie wegen ja auch ab das risiko
zu erkranken ob sie ungeimpft sind oder
geimpft sind und wenn ich herrn nagel
richtig verstanden habe es zumindest bis
zur delta variante es eindeutig
nachgewiesen dass diejenigen die geimpft
waren entweder gar nicht angesteckt gar
nicht infiziert worden sind oder aber
mit milderen verlauf durch die krankheit
den durchgekommen sind auch das ist ja
eine abdeckung gesichtspunkt den sie für
sich berücksichtigen müssen und
sicherlich auch berücksichtigt haben
ja und wie gesagt
so klar war das ja nicht in dieser zweig
phase sind die zeiger dennoch sehr hoch
gegangen auch unter den diensten
und kann was ich gerne noch ergänzen
würde wenn wir über mögliche
nebenwirkungen beziehungsweise werse
effekte sprechen da würde ich gerne ganz
kurz das aufgreifen was sie erfüllt
vorhin gesagt haben sie haben von den
zusatzstoffen gesprochen gehen der link
stoffen enthalten sind das finde ich
ganz spannenden punkt da würde ich gerne
etwas ergänzen mit diesen zusatzstoffen
wie sie angesprochen haben sind die nano
lipide in mein das ist diese
hülle diese schutzhülle die den
eigentlichen sinn stoff also die
messenger rna umgibt
und wiesen am lipide die sind gar nicht
so einfach herzustellen das ist ein
relativ
aufwendiges kompliziertes verfahren
und
die sind auch dafür verantwortlich unter
anderem dass unsere impfstoffe bislang
eine note zulassung haben die verlängert
worden ist und es wurde bisher keine
reguläre zulassung beantragt weil
nämlich
immer auflagen nicht erfüllt worden sind
die daten bezüglich dieser name die
pläne betreffen
immer hat
weitere studien angefordert zur
pharmakokinetik
dieser nano lipide pharmakokinetik ganz
kurz bedeutet wie verteilt sich ein
wirkstoff im körper oder wo akkumuliert
es sich möglicherweise auch und bei den
alpinen ist die pharmakokinetik
unklar
nachzulesen im british medical journal
märz 20 21 und daran hat sich bis zum
heutigen tage nichts geändert aber
vergesst das ist ja keine besonderheit
dieses impfstoffs sondern soweit ich
weiß braucht jeder impfstoff ein
trägermaterial weshalb dieser impfstoff
hat und das trägermaterial ist von der
ehemann natürlich genauso untersucht
worden wie wie bei anderen impfstoffen
in der vergangenheit und ich glaube noch
mal darauf hinweisen so weit ich richtig
informiert bin arbeiten wir in
deutschland zurzeit nicht mit einer note
zulassung sondern die impfstoffe sind
zugelassen für ein jahr und können
danach im zuge der wissenschaftlichen
forschung
natürlich auch optimiert werden und alle
hoffen wir darauf dass die impfstoffe
die im ersten jahr zugelassen werden
auch mit den weiteren varianten die wir
erleben und durchleben
optimiert und angepasst werden das ist
doch auch klug und richtig so warum
leider gleich zwei mal wieder sprechen
herr steinmeier zum einen haben die
impfstoffe tatsächlich derzeit eine note
zulassung die verlängern wurde daran hat
sich nichts geändert
und zum anderen sind diese name lipide
tatsächlich eine besonderheit der
endstufe die sind bis aber das heißt ja
dass hier angewandten stoffen nicht zum
einsatz gekommen nein aber ich habe ihn
ja gesagt alle diese impfstoffe brauchen
trägermaterialien und diese
trägermaterialien für die emea
impfstoffe sind ja nicht untersucht
geblieben durch durch die ema sondern
sind genauso auf ihre nachteiligen
wirkungen hin untersucht worden frau
bestand sie was sagen auflagen gemacht
und diese auflagen sind bisher von den
herstellern nicht erfüllt wenn ich das
noch ganz kurz den kreis schließen darf
warum wir das so wichtig ist mit der
pharmakokinetik
das hat nämlich auswirkungen auf die
frage ob gegen stoffe möglicherweise
langzeit folgen haben können man sagt ja
immer
langzeitfolgen sind ausgeschlossen
sowas gibt es nicht die impfstoffe sind
sicher
jetzt ist es aber so dass sich wie
gesagt diese nano lipide möglicherweise
irgendwo in organen akkumulieren könnten
jetzt ganz neu
ist die autorin hepatitis anerkannt
worden als mögliche seltene
als möglicher seltener effekt bei der
impfungen und da ist tatsächlich in der
diskussion ob das an einer solchen
anreicherung der name liquide in der
leber liegen könnte dass plötzlich das
eigene immunsystem die leber angreift
verbesserte ich glaube frau beach hat
vorhin ganz zutreffend darauf
hingewiesen
die impfstoffe können keine
hundertprozentige wirkung zeigen sie
können auch nicht zu 100%
nebenwirkungen ausschließen
die vorgaben die bei uns gemacht werden
in europa gemacht werden zur einführung
und zulassung eines impfstoffes sind
weltweiter standard und sie sollen über
drei
studienphasen sicherstellen dass die
befürchteten nebenwirkungen
so gering wie möglich sind am ende ist
das nicht nur ein abwägungsprozess
sondern aus schließungs prozess der von
der forschung und der medizinischen
wissenschaft so weit wie möglich
betrieben werden muss frau beach können
sie etwas sagen zu dem thema nur
zulassung meines wissens ist das keine
not zulassung die wir in deutschland
haben
das kann ich ihnen jetzt ein ganz
konkret auch nicht sagen weil das ich in
meinem fachbereich liegt ich bin ja
psychologin aber ich würde dich noch mal
einer bedingten zu lassen
und es besteht die möglichkeit geben
das auf ein jahr festzulegen diesen
bedingte zulassung oder auch um ein jahr
zu verlängern ja aber das ist da ich in
sachsen zeitraums von fünf jahren aber
gesprächen zulassungen notfall zu lassen
das was wir in amerika notfall nutzer
zulassung ist genau das was wir in den
usa haben was wir in großbritannien
haben begleitet durch
haftungsausschlüsse haben wir nicht wir
haben eine bedingte zulassung die davon
ausgeht dass eine optimierung der
impfstoffe im verlaufe der zeit noch
möglich ist und entsprechend die
zulassung noch angepasst werden können
das ist das ist aber aus meiner sicht
deshalb rate ich so darauf römer
vergesse dass bisher kein argument gegen
den impfstoff und gegen das impfen
sondern aus meiner sicht eher einer
dafür frau habe dort ich hätte noch eine
ganz andere frage anfrage hat und herr
füllt sie wissen dass es eine
einrichtung bezogene impfpflicht für
krankenhäuser gibt wie stehen sie denn
dieser im pflicht gegenüber
ja ich kann da gerne antworten ich bin
generell gegen jegliche form der pflicht
mein motto je gilt einer freien
entscheidung und das muss
selbstverständlich auch für
medizinisches personal gelten das könnte
aber dann möglicherweise zur folge haben
dass nicht mehr viel medizinisches
personal vor ort ist weil sie zu hause
sind beide erkrankt sind oder in
quarantäne sind würde ich befürchte
ehrlich gesagt gerade den umgekehrten
gefällt dass wir medizinisches personal
verlieren durch die impfpflicht
in meinem bekanntenkreis gibt es mehrere
fälle wo leute sagen ich liebe meinen
beruf aber wenn die impfpflicht kommt
bin ich raus
ich glaube dass das gar nicht so der
treibende faktor ist die einrichtung
bezogen der impfpflicht für eine flucht
aus dem beruf sondern eigentlich für
eine dauerhafte belastung und das seit
mehreren jahren also es gab vorher schon
einen pflegenotstand
mit beginn der pandemie ist diese
situation definitiv verschärft worden
weil einfach der workload in der klinik
extrem hoch ist und überhaupt nicht mehr
ab forschung sind bei ihnen kolleginnen
und kollegen gegangen wegen der
impfpflicht nein bis jetzt noch nicht
wir warten erstmal ab was am 15 passiert
was ich noch mal sagen möchte vergessen
sie haben ja gesagt dass die impfung bis
jetzt noch nichts gebracht hat ich kann
jetzt einfach mal aus meinem beruflichen
alltag oder über meinen beruflichen
alltag sprechen ich bin der leiter in
einer senioreneinrichtung und wir haben
im ersten jahr der pandemie wirklich
sehr gedankt und sag mal so unsere
einrichtung ist wirklich noch gut über
die runden gekommen wir halten nur ein
kleines ausbruchsgeschehen aber ich kann
auch von kolleginnen berichten da sind
sehr sehr viele senioren verstorben und
das ist einfach eine ganz schreckliche
situation und wir haben uns sehr auf
diese impfung gefreut und waren gleich
im januar bereit auch die ersten impf
teams zu empfangen das hat wunderbar
geklappt alle senioren waren bereit sich
impfen zu lassen und war wirklich sehr
glücklich darüber und ich kann nur sagen
dass wir im letzten jahr
so gut wie gar keine probleme hatten mit
irgendwelchen
erkrankungen oder corona infektionen und
ich denke mal das ist auch ein zeichen
dafür dass die impfung auch wirkt und
dass die mitarbeiter geimpft und die
bewohner geimpft und das ist eine sehr
sehr hohe herdenimmunität in den
pflegeeinrichtungen die wird man
wahrscheinlich hier draußen in der
freien wildbahn sozusagen gar nicht
erreichen können wir haben uns nochmal
richtig zu stellen ich glaube niemand
hier in der runde und am allerwenigsten
ich habe behauptet ihm vom gericht
natürlich noch die info so etwas würde
ich nie sagen aber er die mobilität da
möchte ich ihnen noch mal widersprechen
herdenimmunität kann nicht die rede sein
weil wir auch geimpfte das virus weiter
gehen können was mir jetzt aber ganz
wichtig ist noch mal zu sagen weil ich
das vorher auch schon gesagt wie ich mir
das vorstelle
den ausweg
meine meinung ist an der stelle muss
unser gesundheitssystem
gestärkt werden muss resilient gemacht
werden die pflegeberufe müssen
aufgewertet werden man könnte
beispielsweise an eine akademisierung
der ausbildung denken man müsste die
kompetenzen ausbauen dann müsste
angemessen bezahlen müsst ihr bessere
arbeitsbedingungen schaffen all das wir
helfen denn bisher ist nichts geschehen
aus ein bisschen applaus und eine
bevorstehende ins pflicht das reicht
nicht
frank esser das führt jetzt etwas ab
nach meinem eindruck weil das sind jetzt
forderungen die würde jeder
unterschreiben aber helfen in der
debatte über die impfung und die
impfpflicht nicht so recht weiter
deshalb
oder weiß ich gehen wegen der ins licht
insofern ist es schon wichtig mal zu was
mit dem pflegenotstand ist wie man da ab
helfen kann ja aber sie haben ja
unterstellt dass die pflegekräfte vor
allen dingen wegen der impfpflicht geht
nach dem was ich jetzt von den beiden
kolleginnen hier
oder was was die beiden gäste von ihren
kolleginnen und kollegen berichtet haben
ist das jedenfalls ganz offensichtlich
nicht der fall oder wie ist es bei ihnen
diskutiert oder sie haben ja ein etwas
größeren einblick
definitiv nicht also sie die kollegen
verlassen die
pflege einfach aus dem grund weil sie
über belastet sind und nicht weil sie
geimpft sein müssen wie es an der schule
mit lehrerinnen und lehrern das ist
genauso also die die meisten kollegen
und kollegen sind ja geimpft oder wollen
geimpft sein und und ich sprechen habe
ich noch niemanden gehört der gesagt hat
wenn in der pflicht kommt wenn ich jetzt
mal in meinem beruf sein lassen sondern
im gegenteil die meisten sehen ist halt
als als chance und auch als irgendein
pflicht in dieser institutionen sein
bestes zu tun um jeden zu schützen
wenn wir noch mal ein bisschen zurück
schauen uns ins vergangene jahr ein jahr
in dem wir gehofft hatten die pandemie
zu überwinden das war nicht der fall
aber ein jahr in dem wir
erfreulicherweise
mit hilfe neu entwickelter impfstoff die
delta variante einigermaßen überstanden
haben impfstoffe die auch geschützt
haben weitgehend geschützt haben gegen
neuinfektionen wenn wir jetzt mit blick
auf die zukunft und den umgang mit der
omicron variante
diskutieren
da gibt es einerseits natürlich eine
sichtweise die sie auch vorgetragen
haben frau äußerte food eine sichtweise
die davon ausgeht
dass die bisherigen impfstoffe nicht
ausreichend schützen gegen die infektion
mit der omicron variante
und ich kann daraus den schluss ziehen
und deshalb macht das mit dem impfen
wenig sinn
oder ich sage
weil die bisher entwickelten impfstoffe
gegen die delta variante
effizient gewesen sind muss sich
eigentlich darauf setzen dass die jetzt
stattfindende anpassung der impfstoffe
auch gegen die gegen die omikron
variante hilft das ist doch eigentlich
das was mich stärker überzeugen würde
sie nicht
wir sind doch bereits mittendrin in der
mikrowelle und die angepassten
impfstoffe sind noch gar nicht da die
anderen
pflicht haben mit einem dann verfügbar
die welle ist doch jetzt
wie wir werden die impfstoffe jedenfalls
nach den jüngsten zeitungsmeldungen
wahrscheinlich erst im märz kriegen aber
die omikron variante wird auch nicht die
letzte variante sein mit der wir
umzugehen haben insofern ist ja die
frage
können wir es uns eigentlich leisten in
der gegenwärtigen situation abzuwarten
wie sich die nächsten wellen verhalten
oder müssen wir als gesellschaft nicht
ein interesse daran haben bestmöglichen
impfschutz gegen zukünftige wellen zu
haben
also da ist glaube ich die
wissenschaftliche lage im moment sehr
klar das dreifache impfung ist sehr gut
gegen schwere erkrankung
hospitalisierung hilft und ich glaube
man muss noch mal diesen soliden aspekt
ein bisschen genauer betrachten denn ja
es gibt keine herrn immunität hier und
auch geimpfte können erkranken aber
letztendlich ist ja die vom bag option
für leute die sagen ich lasse mich nicht
impfen ist dann ich kann gehe ich halt
im krankenhaus und darm ist dass dieses
narrativ sage ich mal dieses
überlasteten gesundheitswesens ist jetzt
zu gegner maßen nach zwei jahren
vielleicht ein bisschen ausgelutscht
aber es wird ja immer brenzliger und es
liegt ja daran dass wir immer nur
darüber reden das gesundheitssystems
überlassen würde ich mir vielleicht
reicht von barock noch mal wünsche dann
einblick wie ist denn der alltag da
total an der front ich glaube das wird
vergessen wer es ist eine egoistische
entscheidung sich nicht impfen zu lassen
beim
aus weil man sagt meine kosten nutzen
abwägungen ergibt ich möchte mich nicht
impfen lassen und wenn ich krank werde
ich halt ins krankenhaus es ist okay
egoistisch zu sein aber es kann halt in
einer gesellschaft nicht jeder
egoistisch sein denn so wie wenn man
über eine wiese geht und man sieht
nichts wenn 20 leute jeden tag über
diese wiese gehen entsteht dann weg und
genauso ist es auch wenn alle leute
sagen ich bin egoistisch und das nicht
mich impfen dann stehen wir vor einer
situation wo die pflege wo ärzte aus den
krankenhäusern sein ich kann nicht mehr
ich kündige ich mache etwas anderes ich
glaube dass das schon punkt der würde
mir jetzt hier der fehlt mir noch ein
bisschen dass wir vielleicht gleich aus
dem innern noch ausführen was wir hier
ehre gehen in dieser debatte eine
sekunde bitter ist dass wir ganz viel
von dieser diskussion fernab von all
unserer kompetenz verbracht haben
nämlich wo wir über irgendwelche die
titel gesprochen haben wohl niemand von
uns die fachkompetenz hat das richtig
einzuordnen ich wünsche mir im
nachhinein gerne ein faktencheck für
ganz viele dieser dinge die wir hier
gesagt haben von uns allen denn dass es
noch mal ganz wichtig weil wir uns da in
kleinigkeiten verlieren ich würde es
damit nicht runterspielen ich bin nur
sagen wir müssen da
sehr klar wie fakten checken und will
und das wissenschaftlich einordnen damit
wir risiken gegeneinander abwägen können
frau goetsch das ist vollkommen richtig
und ich werde alles was ich hier heute
gesagt habe sehr gerne belegen ich habe
für alles quellenangaben die kann ich im
bundespräsidialamt zur verfügung stellen
und dann wäre ich dankbar für einen
faktencheck denn ich bin ja auch
interessiert daran gut informiert zu
sein also ich werde alle meine quellen
zur verfügung stellen und
ich sehe es nicht als kleinigkeit an
über langzeitfolgen hat merkt
dass hier keiner keiner keiner
vernachlässigt
langzeitfolgen und
jeder ist bereit über langzeitfolgen
tatsächlich auch zu diskutieren die die
frage ist doch nur in einer abwägung in
der wir alle sind den risiken einer
pandemie die leider immer noch kein ende
genommen hat bei der in deutschland
glaube ich inzwischen jetzt ungefähr 100
13.000 menschen gestorben sind
mit und nach einer infektion
können wir doch nicht darüber hinweg
gehen dass wir ein interesse daran haben
die zahl der todesfälle der schweren
erkrankungen in zukunft kleiner zu
halten und vor allen dingen das ist der
solidar aspekt den frau wird eben
erwähnt hat wir können nicht darüber
hinweg gehen dass wir
verdrängungs entscheidungen in den
kliniken im augenblick fällen ich weiß
nicht wie es bei ihnen am ort und im
nächstgelegenen krankenhaus ist aber
auch hier in der region werden menschen
zwar nicht verwiesen aber auf andere
krankenhäuser verwiesen weil
möglicherweise noch nicht die letzte
grenzbelastung erreicht es aber wir uns
wieder einen punkt nähern wo die
auslastung der krankenhäuser und auch in
der in den identen situationen erreicht
wird und deshalb ist die ist die debatte
über nebenfolgen nebenwirkungen nicht
vernachlässigbar aber wenn wir
verantwortungsvolle entscheidungen
treffen die nicht nur für mich
persönlich relevant sind sondern die
auch
die gesundheit und das recht auf
gesundheit der anderen in der
gesellschaft wahrt müssen wir doch einen
abwägungsprozess machen in dem all diese
gesichtspunkte berücksichtigt werden
sonst ist es die freiheit des normalen
über die über über den wir leben die
freiheit des eremiten über den wir über
die wir reden aber nicht die freiheit
eines menschen in einer gesellschaft in
der wir wie sich selbst gesagt haben
ganz am anfang gemeinsam
über die runden kommen wollen und das
gemeinsame interesse ist doch dass wir
irgendwann hoffentlich in überschaubarer
zeit wieder in normale verhältnisse
zurückkehren können die vielleicht nicht
ganz so sein werden wie in status quo
ante aber bei denen wir doch erhoffen
dass wir uns im sozialen verhalten
wieder üben können dass schülerinnen und
schüler keine angst davor haben müssen
in den digitalen unterricht verbannt zu
werden das in krankenhäusern und
alteneinrichtungen
angehörige ihre dort betreuten eltern
und großeltern wieder besuchen können
das ist doch der weg nachdem wir suchen
müssen und der hängt im zweifel nicht an
den lippen herr bundespräsident das ist
ein ganz wichtiger punkt und deswegen
würde ich das gerne noch ganz kurz mit
zahlen und fakten untermauern
damit wir nicht über lipide reden
sondern über tatsachen ich habe mir mal
hier vorgenommen die offiziellen zahlen
des rk ii vom 4 januar dieses jahres
und wenn wir dabei schauen auf diesen
hin stationen waren am vierten januar
neun personen ab 18
und sechs von diesen neun waren
wenn wir uns die todesfälle anschauen am
selben tag
dann kommen wir auch sieben und fünf
davon waren und drei von diesen fünf
sogar mit auffrischungsimpfung
also da muss ich auch ihnen frau
professor bates widersprechen das
relativiert auch die behauptung dass
ungeimpfte
egoistische reise die krankenhäuser film
ja ich glaube das hat frau beko in
erklärt dass die dass die schutzwirkung
der impfung der vollständigen impfung
vor allen dingen gegen die delta
variante wirkte dass sie leider entgegen
unseren hoffnungen oder sagen wir gehen
gegen den hoffnungen der forscher und
entwickler nicht ausreichend gegen die
omikron variante sorgt aber es ist doch
kein argument gegen das impfen sondern
sie müssten doch eigentlich ein
interesse daran haben mindestens die
bekam mindestens sozusagen in den in den
genuss der begrenzten schutzwirkung zu
kommen so lange die vollständige
schutzwirkung gegen die omikron variante
noch nicht auf dem markt ist oder sehe
ich das falsch ja nochmal ich allmend
ihre doch nicht gegen das sind
keineswegs ich habe mich nur gerade
verliert gegen den gegen die behauptung
dass zwei egoistisch wenn jemand sich
nicht impfen lässt wenn die zahlen
sprechen eine klare sprache
das baut das glauben aber freie
entscheidung keine impfpflicht ja aber
die zahlen sprechen eben keine klare
sprache sondern wenn ich das wenn ich
das richtig in erinnerung habe ich muss
das jetzt mal zusammen haben dann haben
wir ungefähr 21 millionen menschen in
deutschland die nicht geimpft sind davon
sind
vier millionen kinder zwischen null und
vier jahren für die es bisher keinen
empfohlenen impfstoff gibt und es gibt
vor gessert auch darauf hinzuweisen drei
millionen menschen die medizinische
indikationen haben die keine impfung zu
lassen die sind schon mal außen vor das
heißt aber wenn ich jetzt richtig rechne
dann haben wir 14 millionen menschen in
deutschland die sich
aus unterschiedlichen gründen
ernstzunehmenden weniger ernst zu
nehmenden gründen bisher nicht
entschlossen haben sich impfen zu lassen
herr nagel was mit was bedeutet diese
größenordnung von 14 millionen menschen
die sich impfen lassen könnten aber
nicht impfen lassen für für ihre
modellierung der näheren zukunft
und ich gehe über die omikron variante
durchaus in eine perspektive in der wir
noch weitere varianten erleben wird
danke
also ich will vielleicht mal gerade
jetzt schon angesprochen worden dass das
an irgendeiner stelle natürlich auch
irgendwie dieses problem der
wissenschaftlichen arbeitsteilung
auftritt mich und ich hab vorher
versucht auch gerade als antwort auf
begeistert einiges zu sagen wo ich wie
soll ich sagen also vielleicht jetzt
nicht der gleichen meinung wenn aber
doch zumindest die argumente gerne
aufnehmen weil ich weiß dass er sagen
kann jetzt sind wir zwischendurch
irgendwo hin gerutscht wo ich zumindest
nicht besonders viel sagen kann und das
ist natürlich immer mal sagen viel für
den debatte auch irgendwie schwierig
wenn dann argumente genommen werden
wofür wir das personal nicht da ist also
oder ich sag mal positiv ich selber als
wissenschaft glaube an
wissenschaftlicher arbeitsteilung und
wenn es leute gibt die sagen sie gucken
sich die insekten ordentlich an dann
muss ich also ich glaube daran einfach
weil ich das system punkte noch kenne
aber an irgendeiner stelle muss ich auch
glauben dass die leute das ordentlich
machen und was dann halt immer bleibt
das jetzt auch schon angesprochen worden
wir haben halten impfrisiko und ich
glaube das ist da und dass wir wie
gesagt haben dass das nicht existiert
also sozusagen ein impfstoff sicher ist
es auch ein bisschen deutsche
sprachprobleme haben das beim
bauingenieuren auch nicht die brücke ist
sicher aber natürlich trotzdem
zusammenstutzen also der sprachgebrauch
ist da auch ein bisschen schwierig dann
müssen wir sicher präziser werden aber
wir haben halt auf der anderen seite
auch risiken und das ist jetzt immer
wieder angesprochen worden wir haben
eben nicht nur das eigene risiko wo
jetzt ja offenbar verbessert das
sozusagen das imwf risiko höher
einschätzt als das infektionsrisiko oder
ich weiß es nicht aber das ist ja okay
sozusagen
und kann also das visum sagen dass im
risiko wie soll ich sagen also da in ihm
risiko sehen aber wir haben ja eben auf
der anderen seite auch das risiko was
wir ja angesprochen haben dass das
gesundheitssystem überlastet wird dass
sich das dass die schulbildung
vernachlässigt und so weiter nicht wo
wir sicher auf der gegenseite und an
irgendeiner stelle muss ich mich halt
auch verlassen dass die
risikoeinschätzung risiko einschätzt und
kollegen halbwegs richtig sind dann
möchte ich da eine entscheidung treffen
und jetzt in dem sinne mit dem money
management ist glaube ich schon dass wir
uns darüber verständigen müssen wie wir
eine impfpflicht eigentlich sehen würden
also sehen wir das so als eine
grundimmunisierung das heißt es gibt
einen schutz gegen schwerem verlauf da
gibt es auch natürlich noch keine
endgültigen daten also noch ein wenig
aber das scheint ja doch so zu sein wenn
man das hat egal ob über infektionen
also über genesung oder über ebenso dass
das mindestens einen faktor 4 ist
wahrscheinlich sogar ein bisschen mehr
von symptomatik ist und den sieg
stationen also sagen schutz gegen sport
ist auf jeden fall noch mal höher das
reduziert die belastung des systems das
ist wahrscheinlich relativ lange haltbar
das wäre etwas muss man sagen könnte wir
machen jetzt was er sich in form und
wenn dann damit auf und wenn jemand
stattdessen die infektion durchgemacht
hat akzeptieren wird es auch und die
alternative ist dass wir sagen wir
wollen eine aktive pandemie steuerung
betreiben was eben nicht nur dieser
schutz gegen schweren verlauf ist
sondern eben auch dieser schutz gegen
übertragen und der schutz gegen
übertragung hält halt nur um die vier
monate der liegt möglicherweise daneben
will jetzt gerade willkommen gesehen
haben oder das problem habe bei körper
auch möchtest grippeimpfung mal den
falschen die falsche variante erwischen
kann und dann haben wir deutlich größere
probleme im winter danach und wenn wir
diesen weg gehen dann braucht man
irgendwie eine überlegung wie die eben
dieses update management betreiben und
gerade in hinblick auf kommen würde das
vielleicht auch bedeuten dass wenn der
weltweit des südens brauchen denn ich
meine omi com geht es ja tatsächlich
schon länger und das wäre das dann
relativ früh feststellen und
entsprechend gegen impfstoffe machen und
das ist wahrscheinlich richtig dass wir
jetzt endlich auch mikron variante das
zu spät kommt aber ich glaube auch nikon
hätte man durchaus weltweiten monat
früher finden können wenn wir jetzt uns
angucken wie die produktionstechnologie
hier ist es das ja nicht aussichtslos
dass wir das damit hingekriegt hätte und
ich finde schon das sind dinge über die
wir reden
könnten wie wir das eigentlich wollen
also ich weiß nicht vielleicht ist ja
eine grundimmunisierung als nicht
akzeptabel aber das update management
nicht oder beides letztlich akzeptabel
oder wir akzeptieren sozusagen
immunisierung durch infektionen das ist
ja sozusagen die alternative das etwas
andere risiko was da steht wenn wir uns
nicht impfen lassen sagen das ist jetzt
halt jahren weise ich will meine runde
in dieser gesellschaft wollen dann
müssen wir vielleicht auch die
ressourcen dafür bereitstellen in der
intensivmediziner und wenn man dann noch
einmal durch jetzt ist vielleicht auch
gut also ich glaube das wäre so die
spannbreite wo ich vielleicht auch er
selber spreche ich bin als jetzt bei
selten auftretenden ins nebenwirkungen
wie gesagt hat muss ich mich darauf
verlassen die risiken gibt es aber ich
schätze sie als kleiner als das für sie
können natürlich gemacht nicht aktion
frau gestern der foto und auch an die
gäste hier im bellevue eine eine
abschließende frage wir sind jetzt mehr
als anderthalb stunden fast
eindreiviertel stunden lang im gespräch
wenn sie aus diesem gespräch heraus
gehen gibt es eigentlich
argumente gedanken
[Musik]
hinweise die sie aus einem solchen
gespräch mit nehmen und in ihre
zukünftigen überlegungen und gedanken
zum impfen zu impfpflicht mit einbauen
oder haben sie aus ihrer sicht nichts
neues gehört worüber sich nachzudenken
lohnt erfurt
ich nehme auf jeden fall mit schöner
weise dass wir eigentlich alle ergebnis
erwarten dass das gleiche ziel haben wir
wollen das ende der pandemie
herbeiführen
für mich sehr interessant und
aufschlussreich waren im prinzip die
drucke von vorn forscher dort unsere
chance
dass das manchmal sehr sehr interessant
zu wissen wie es bei in den
einrichtungen da abläuft und wie die
haltung dort zu einer impfpflicht ist
das ist für mich neu das muss ich
wirklich sagen in den eindruck hatte ich
so bislang noch nicht gewonnen aber das
nehme ich auf jeden fall mit
verbessert
ja was ich vor allem mitnehmen das ist
die art und weise wie wir miteinander
gesprochen haben die offene atmosphäre
und der
tatsachen und im ehrlichen austausch
bemühte diskurs das habe ich sehr sehr
wohltuend empfunden und das würde ich
mir auch wünschen dass das öfter
stattfindet im gesamtgesellschaftlichen
diskurs
da wäre auch mein wunsch dass
politiker
regierungsmitglieder ihrem beispiel herr
bundespräsident
folgen und mehr ins gespräch gehen mit
den menschen mehr zu hören
und ich fand es auch sehr schön dass die
presse heute dabei war und wie ich
gehört habe reges interesse an unserem
gespräch gezeigt hat das wäre ein
weiterer wunsch von mir und das kann ich
ihnen noch nicht bestätigen das haben
sie wahrscheinlich jetzt parallel
genauer verfolgt als ich jetzt hier
verfolgen konnte aber es ist presse im
raum und viele schauen auch über den
livestream zu
dieses interesse freut mich und das wäre
ich mitnehmen weil ich mir auch wünschen
würde dass in der öffentlichen
diskussion in der öffentlichen debatte
wieder mehr meinungspluralität möglich
ist das fair und offen berichtet wird
und man argumente austauschen kann so
wie wir das hier heute getan haben ja
und dazu gehört glaube ich auch dass
die benennung der probleme die wir haben
insbesondere auch dass eine objektiv zu
niedrigen impfquote nicht
missverstanden wird als der versuch der
ausgrenzung sondern
dass es teil eines versuches ist
den weg in die normalität
zurückzufinden und einen umgang mit der
infektion mit der infektionskrankheit zu
finden der es uns erlaubt unsere
gesundheitswesens stabil zu halten und
die vielen anderen die ihr auch ihr
recht auf gesundheit mit möglicherweise
anderen krankheiten dass die ihr recht
auf gesundheit auch weiterhin
durch ordnungsgemäße behandlung in den
krankenhäusern nicht nur auf den
intensivstationen
erfüllt sehen
argumente die sie hier gehört haben und
die sie möglicherweise mit einbeziehen
in ihre überlegungen zur impfung zur
pflicht im winter also ich finde es auch
sehr schön zu hören wie wie groß die
bereitschaft auch in den pflege- und
gesundheitseinrichtungen ist da wo ich
hatte mal auch der kampf gegen dieses
virus an vorderster front geführt wird
aber auch dass ich sage mal bei
denjenigen die der sache ist skeptisch
gegenüberstehen dass er durchaus
gesprächsbedarf vorhanden ist und ja und
man sich auch gedanken macht über dieses
thema
ich glaube ich kann die diskussion auch
wirklich sehr hilfreich ich glaube auch
dass wir aus dieser situation aus dieser
pandemie situation etwas für das
gesundheitswesen in zukunft ableiten
müssen nämlich einen besseren zugang zu
guten informationen also dass die
bevölkerung auch eine wirklich gute
gesundheitskompetenz aufbauen kann und
dann auch eine informierte entscheidung
treffen kann mit evidenzbasierten
informationen
dankeschön saison ja ich fand diese
diskussion auch wirklich sehr
interessant und ich für mich war noch
mal wirklich sehr wichtig
zu wissen dass man wirklich im gespräch
bleiben muss auch mit menschen die
wirklich
auch sorgen haben sich impfen zu lassen
und dass man durch dieses gespräch
vielleicht auch
verständnis gegenseitig hat und
ja dass das aber der der wunsch trotzdem
gemeinsam da ist gegen diese pandemie
auch etwas zu unternehmen und auch den
beitrag zu leisten
ja vielen dank und ich bedanke mich bei
ihnen allen für die bereitschaft zu
diesem gespräch
es ist nicht das gespräch mit der
gesellschaft insgesamt diejenigen die
hier vertreten waren als befürworter
oder als skeptiker der impfpflicht
haben sozusagen stellvertretend
diskutiert für viele andere
hunderttausende millionen die an diesem
gespräch jetzt nicht teilnehmen konnten
bzw
nur als zuhörer teilnehmen konnten
was mir noch zu denken gibt es sein
kommentar den ich heute morgen in einer
großen deutschen tageszeitung gesehen
habe den frankfurt erscheint ein
kommentator der sich gedanken darüber
macht
was ist eigentlich die folge wenn wir
unseren impfschutz in der gesellschaft
nicht weiter erhöhen und
kommt zu dem ergebnis
wenn das bedeutet dass wir auch in
zukunft bei weiteren varianten wieder
mit kontakt beschränkungen mit lockdown
zu kämpfen haben
sind das wirklich vertretbare mittel mit
denen wir leben wollen mit psychischen
schäden mit verschuldung künftiger
generationen
mit einer situation in der taufen
hochzeiten trauerfeiern
nicht stattfinden können oder nur
eingeschränkt stattfinden können auch
das sind eingriffe nicht nur die impfung
und die impfpflicht sind eingriffe
sondern auch das was möglicherweise bei
einer nicht erhöhung der impfquote
ebenfalls an einschränkungen zu erleben
sein wird insofern
wird das alles abzuwägen sein und wird
sich wiederfinden in den debatten die
auch im deutschen bundestag in den
nächsten wochen ende dieses monats
insbesondere geführt werden aber ich
freue mich darüber der sich heute mit
ganz unterschiedlichen vertretern und
positionen aus der gesellschaft und mit
zwei wissenschaftlern einer
wissenschaftlerin reden durfte
herzlichen dank für ihre bereitschaft
und alles gute
danke herzlichen dank an sie herr
bundespräsident